ALRIGHT GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYBODY.
WE ARE GOING TO START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE JUST A REMINDER WE
HAVE THREE MINUTES PER SIDE.
HER TESTIMONY THREE PEOPLE
BANKERS.
I WAS STARTING FILE ITEM ONE A.
B. SEVENTEEN THIRTY FOUR MISTER
CALDERON WOULD YOU LIKE TO OPEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AB SEVENTY THIRTY FOUR
WILL EXTEND THE SUCCESSFUL
CALIFORNIA FILM AND TELEVISION
PRODUCTION TAX CREDIT FEW
INDUSTRIES ARE MORE. INDELIBLY
TIED TO A LOCATION IN THE
INTENDED ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY
IS TO CALIFORNIA THIS INDUSTRY
CREATES HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
GOOD PAYING JOBS.
MIDDLE CLASS JOBS IN BE
BILLIONS AND GENERATES BILLIONS
IN ECONOMIC ACTIVITY THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA EACH YEAR AND.
HOPEFUL STILL FLOCK TO THE AREA
WITH THE DREAM OF BIG BEING
DISCOVERED UNFORTUNATELY SINCE
THE LATE NINETEEN NINETIES.
OTHER STATES AND COUNTRIES HAVE
LOWER PRODUCTION OUT OF
CALIFORNIA GENEROUS TAX BREAKS
IN THOSE YEARS OF RUNAWAY
PRODUCTION CALIFORNIA SUFFERED.
MASSIVE LOSSES OF JOBS REVENUE
INVESTMENT AND THE EROSION OF
THE FILM INDUSTRY THE TOLL ON
WORKERS OF FAMILIES WHAT THE MAN
SAYS THE FILM CREWS. AND MEMBERS
TRAVEL TO OTHER STATES
FOLLOWING WORK LEAVING BEHIND
THEIR FAMILIES AND FACE
UNEMPLOYMENT HOME AN EFFORT TO
COMBAT THAT. FIGHT THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED THE REGIONAL
VERSION OF THE TAX CREDIT TO
DOES NINE.
AND THE PROGRAM HAS BEEN
APPROVED IMPROVED UPON OF THE
YEARS THE PRODUCTION TAX CREDIT
INCENTIVES.
INCENTIVIZE THE CREATION OF
GOOD PAYING MIDDLE CLASS BELOW
THE LINE JOBS FOR WORKERS WHO
WOULD DO TECHNICAL WORK CREATING
PROPS BUILDING SETS APPLYING
MAKE UP FINDING LOCATIONS AND
ALL THE WORK BEHIND THE SCENES
THAT MAKES PRODUCTION POSSIBLE.
THE BENEFITS EXTEND BEYOND THE
THOUSANDS OF EMPLOYEES IN THE
FILM AND TELEVISION PRODUCTION
AYE INDUSTRY TO THE ANCILLARY
BUSINESSES THAT SERVE. TO
PRODUCTION SITES IN TEAMS SUCH
AS THE CREATORS EXCUSE ME
CATERERS HOTELS SET COULD
CONSTRUCTION COMPANIES IN
RESTAURANTS FURTHER THE STATE AS
A WHOLE BENEFITS AS TAX REVENUE
GENERATED FROM THIS.
THIS PROGRAM HELPS TO PAY FOR
TEACHERS AYE IN THESE THOSE
BUSINESSES PAYS FOR TEACHERS
POLICE OFFICERS AND
INFRASTRUCTURE THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA.
THE TAX CREDIT HAS PROVEN
ATTRACT HAS A PROVEN TRACK
RECORD OF CREATING MET RETAINING
JOBS IN THE FILM INDUSTRY IN
FACT THE FILM COMMISSION
RECENTLY COMPLETED ALL
ALLOCATIONS FOR THE CURRENT
FISCAL YEAR. ACCORDING TO OUR TO
THEIR PRELIMINARY DATA FOR THE
FIRST YEAR FIRST THREE YEARS THE
PROGRAM TO POINT OUT WE HAVE
ALLOCATE ALLOCATED EIGHT EIGHT
HUNDRED AND FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN TAX CREDITS. TO A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY APPROVED
PROJECTS TOGETHER THESE PROJECTS
ARE CONTRIBUTING FIVE POINT NINE
BILLION DOLLARS OF DIRECT IN
STATE SPENDING INCLUDING TWO
POINT THREE BILLION DOLLARS IN
WAGES TO THE TECHNICAL CREW
WHICH EXCLUDES ANY WAGES PAID
FOR WRITERS DIRECTORS. PRODUCERS
ARE ACTORS AS THOSE WAGES ARE
NOT ELIGIBLE FOR TAX CREDITS AND
AS FOR JOBS.
WHICH IS WHAT THIS TAX CREDIT
HAS ALWAYS BEEN ABOUT WE'VE SEEN
A TWELVE PERCENT INCREASE IN
HOURS WORKED TWENTY NINE
THOUSAND CAST MEMBERS HIRED
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND CREW MEMBERS
HIRED AND ANOTHER FOUR HUNDRED
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND. BACKGROUND
HIRES WHICH ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE
HIRED ON A DAILY BASIS WE'VE
ALSO HAD THIRTEEN TV SERIES
RELOCATE TO THE STATE FROM OTHER
STATES THREE SERIES HAVE MOVED
FROM NEW YORK FOR FROM VANCOUVER
THE REST CAME FROM NEW YORK AND
EXCUSE ME NORTH CAROLINA.
MARYLAND TEXAS LOUISIANA AND
FLORIDA IN THE CURRENT PROGRAM
IT ITS SUNSETS IN TWO YEARS ON
IT AND TWENTY TWENTY SO DUE TO
THE COMPLEXITY OF MOTION
PICTURES.
AND TELEVISION PRODUCTION
DECISIONS REGARDING SHOOT
LOCATIONS ARE MADE OFTEN A YEAR
OR MORE IN ADVANCE MOTION
PICTURE AND TELEVISION
PRODUCTIONS NEED CERTAINTY.
OF THE CALIFORNIA FILM
TELEVISION TAX CREDIT PROGRAM
AND IN ORDER TO CONSIDER
CALIFORNIA AS A LOCATION. IN
THEIR PRODUCTION PLANNING THAT'S
WHY WE'RE OFFERING THIS BILL.
WITH ME TODAY IT'S A GOOD BILL
OBVIOUSLY SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM MY
TO BELABOR THE POINT.
WITH ME TO TO.
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT I HAVE
ROBERT CICCONE JUNIOR WHO IS
UTILITY WORKER AND MEMBER OF
LABOR'S LOCAL SOME TWENTY FOUR.
AS WELL AS ZACK KIPKE WORTH THE
OPERATIONS MANAGER AT DTC GRIP
IN ELECTRIC OUT OF EMERYVILLE.
THE LARGEST GROUP IN ELECTRIC
HOUSE NORTH OF LOS ANGELES I
ALSO HAVE A ME LET MISSION FROM
THE FILM COMMISSION WHO IS HERE
TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS OF ANY OF THE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE HAVE SOME. ALSO
HAVE MY GREAT JOIN OTHER MISTER
RICHARD BLOOM WITH ME.
MR.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
THAT REVAMPS FILM TAX CREDIT IS
PROVING TO BE AN INCREDIBLE
SUCCESS IT'S PUMPED MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS BACK INTO THE CALIFORNIA
ECONOMY AND.
A AS SAID MISTER CALDERON SAID
THESE DOLLARS FLOWED DIRECTLY
INTO THE POCKETS OF THOUSANDS OF
CASTING CREW MEMBERS EMPLOYED
AND.
GREAT MIDDLE CLASS JOBS.
THEY SUSTAIN HUNDREDS OF SMALL
BUSINESSES INVOLVED IN THE FILM
INDUSTRY AND THEY SUPPORT ENTIRE
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT OUR STATE.
THIS BILL IS ABOUT KEEPING
HOLLYWOOD IN CALIFORNIA WHERE I
WAS BORN. AND WHERE IT BELONGS
BUT THIS BILL IS NOT JUST ABOUT
PRESERVING CALIFORNIA'S LEGACY
IT'S ABOUT THE ECONOMY. JOBS AND
EXTENDING A PROGRAM THAT IS
PROVEN TO WORK EXTREMELY WELL
THANK YOU.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ROBERT
CICCONE JUNIOR AND I LIKE TO
THINK MAJORITY LEADER CALDERON.
CHAIRMAN BURKE. AND CHU AND
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE FOR
INVITING ME HERE TODAY. WHILE
I'M ONLY TWENTY FIVE YEARS OLD.
I HAVE WORKED AS MEMBER OF
LABOR'S LOCAL SEVEN TWENTY FOUR
SINCE I WAS EIGHTEEN.
BEING HERE TODAY IS VERY FAR
FROM MY NORMAL WORKING DAY. BUT
I AM GLAD TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY BECAUSE I FEEL VERY
STRONGLY ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
THE CURRENT CALIFORNIA FILM AND
TELEVISION TAX CREDIT PROGRAM TO
PLANO. AND I WANT TO SPEAK TODAY
IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTEEN
THIRTY FOUR. PRODUCTION PEOPLE
ARE CRAFTS BECAUSE PEOPLE AND
TECHNICIANS THAT WORK BEHIND THE
SCENES TO MAKE IT WHAT YOU SEE
ON SCREEN POSSIBLE WE ARE THE
PEOPLE THAT YOU NEVER SEE OR
HEAR ABOUT. AT THE OSCARS ARE
AND THESE THERE ARE OVER. DOUBT
HUNDRED DOLLARS CLOSE TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND OF US LIVING
AND WORKING HERE IN CALIFORNIA
AND WE ARE THE ONES MOST SEE
DIRECTLY IMPACTED. WHEN A FILM
OR TV SERIES STAYS IN CALIFORNIA
OR WHEN IT LEAVES.
I LIKE TO TAKE A MOMENT AND
EXPLAIN TO YOU WHAT THE WORK I
DO.
THE UTILITY WORKERS ARE THE
PEOPLE WHO BRING THE SET TO
WHERE IT NEEDS TO BE THAT DAY ON
THE STUDIO LOT OR ON LOCATION
AND TAKE IT OVER TAKE IT WHEN
IT'S DONE. AFTER THE DAY IS OVER
THAT MEANS WE START WORK EARLY
MORNING BEFORE MOST OF THE CREW
AND CAST HER ON SET AND EITHER
BREAKING THE SAID DOWN. LATER
THAT NIGHT OR EARLY THE NEXT
MORNING.
THROUGHOUT THE DAY WE ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR MAINTAINING THE
SET AND SUPPORTING THE WORK OF
OTHER CREW MEMBERS SUCH AS
CARPENTERS ELECTRICIANS AND
PAINTERS.
CALIFORNIA'S UP TO ONE OF THE
BEST LOCATIONS IN THE WORLD FOR
FILMING THE STATE OFFERS DIVERSE
LOOKS AND TERRAIN FROM MOUNTAINS
TO OCEANS LAKES FORCE AND DOES
IT WE ALSO HAVE MOST.
THE MOST EXPERIENCED CREWS
HOWEVER MOST DISHES DECISIONS
ARE ABOUT.
ABOUT WHERE TO SHE ARE DRIVEN BY
WHERE WERE YOU CAN PRODUCE A
FILM AT THE LOWEST COST.
AND THAT IS WHY OTHER STATES AND
COUNTRIES HAVE USE INCENTIVES.
TO TAKE PRODUCTION AWAY FROM
CALIFORNIA.
I GREW UP ON FILM SETS BECAUSE I
FOLLOWING MY FATHER'S FOOTSTEPS.
HE JUST RETIRED THIS YEAR AFTER
WORKING IN THE BUSINESS.
BUT AS A MEMBER LOCAL SEVEN
TWENTY FOUR FOR THIRTY FIVE
YEARS ON TV SHOWS LIKE THIRD
ROCK FROM THE SUN AND DON'T SUCH
AS BRUCE ALMIGHTY.
I'M VISITING HIM ON THE SET OF
JURASSIC PARK THE LOST ROAD
SUBMITTED MY DESIRE TO MAKE
WORKING IN THE MOTION PICTURE.
INDUSTRY MY CAREER HOWEVER
DESPITE HIS YEARS OF EXPERIENCE.
I'VE WATCHED HIM FORCED TO GO ON
UNDER POINT OFTEN ON UNEMPLOYED
UNEMPLOYMENT. WHEN SO MANY SO
MANY PRODUCTIONS LEFT CALIFORNIA
BEFORE YOU PASSED AB EIGHTEEN
THIRTY NINE.
AND BROUGHT IT BACK VERY FEW
LABOR HAS GOT ON THE AIRPLANE
WHEN PRODUCTION LEAVES THE STATE
THE GREAT MAJORITY OF US ARE
LEFT BEHIND. SO JUST A FEW YEARS
AGO THERE WERE A LOTOF US
LOOKING FOR WORK AND VERY FEW
JOBS TO COME BY. IT WAS TOUGH TO
SEE SKILLED WORKERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES HAVING IT SO HARD.
I HAD BEEN VERY LUCKY BECAUSE I
GOT HIRED RIGHT OUT OF HIGH
SCHOOL AND HAVE WORKED STEADILY
EVER SINCE. BUT I WAS ALSO
IMPACTED ONE FILM AND TELEVISION
PRODUCTION FOR THE CALIFORNIA.
I WAS VERY HARD FOR ME TO FIND
WORK WHEN PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
WORKING FOR DECADES ARE
STRUGGLING. THEN IT'S ALL THAT
MUCH HARDER FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
LIKE MEAT AND SO CALLED ROOKIES
TO FIND WAYS INTO THE BUSINESS
OR TO KEEP STEADY WORK ONCE WE
HAVE FOUND A JOB I DID
EVERYTHING I COULD TO KEEP FROM
GOING ON UNEMPLOYMENT.
AND WHAT I SAW WAS THAT THE.
WHEN THE FILM AND TELEVISION
PRODUCTION IS GONE PEOPLE MY AGE
CAN'T REALLY FIND WORK.
NOW WITH SO MUCH PRODUCTION BACK
IN THE END DOORS HAVE OPENED UP.
I HAVE BEEN LUCKY ENOUGH TO WORK
ON A FEW INCENTIVE SHOWS SUCH AS
ANIMAL KINGDOM. WHICH SHOOTS ALL
OVER CALIFORNIA A FOREIGNER AND
I'VE BEEN TO PLACES SUCH AS
MULTI STATE PARK AND SILVER
BRAND PRISON IN EAST LOS ANGELES
LAST DECEMBER I WAS HIRED TO
WORK. ON ONE OF THE LIVE TV
MUSICAL PRODUCTIONS THAT
RECEIVED THE CREDIT A CHRISTMAS
STORY LIVE. WORKING ON A LIVE TO
THE TELEVISION SHOW. WAS A A
REALLY HIGH PRESSURE EXPERIENCE
BUT AMONG EVERYONE WORKING ON
THAT PRODUCTION THERE WAS A
SPECIAL BOND AND PRIDE IN BEING
THERE. AND WATCHING ALL OF US
TOGETHER CREATES CREATE A SNOWY
WINTER WONDERLAND.
I WAS A GREAT EXPERIENCE.
MORE POINT OF THE OPPORTUNITY TO
GROW IN MY WORK INOUR BUSINESS
PRODUCTION DECISIONS ARE MADE
ONE OR TWO YEARS IN ADVANCE.
CERTAINTY ABOUT THE FUTURE IS
NEEDED AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY FOUR.
HERE'S OUR IS A JOB CREATOR THAT
EXTENDS THE CURRENT TWO POINT OH
PROGRAM SPEAKING NOT JUST FOR
MYSELF. AND MY FAMILY BUT FOR
ALL THE BELOW THE LINE MEN AND
WOMEN WHO WORK IN THE MOTION
PICTURE BUSINESS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA I THANK YOU AND ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
I'D LIKE TO THANK ALL OF YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY I
MY NAME IS ZAKI WORTH I AM THE
OPERATIONS MANAGER AT A COMPANY
CALLED DTC LIGHTING A GRIP THAT
NAME WAS DECIDED THIRTY YEARS
AGO SO PLEASE DON'T BLAME ME FOR
THE ACRONYM.
LIGHTING AND GRIP FOR THOSE A
FEW WHO DON'T KNOW IT OR YOU
JUST WANT TO BE ABLE TO IMPRESS
YOUR FRIENDS AT THE END OF THE
CREDITS BY KNOWING WHAT A KEY
GRIP WERE BEST LAWYERS. THEY ARE
THE TECHNICIANS THAT ARE IN
CHARGE OF LIGHTING THE SET AND
PROVIDING POWER.
SO THE ELECTRICIANS PROVIDE
POWER AND PROVIDE THE LIGHT IN
THE GRIPS SHAPE THAT LIGHT
OTHER WOULD ALSO ARGUE THAT EACH
ONE OF THEM CARRIES THE OTHER
DEPARTMENT ON THEIR BACK BUT
THAT'S NEITHER HERE NOR THERE.
I BELIEVE I'VE BEEN ASKED TO TO
SPEAK AND I WAS PART OF THE.
EIGHTEEN THIRTY NINE DISCUSSION
FOR YEARS AGO I BELIEVE I'VE
BEEN ASKED HERE AS A
REPRESENTATIVE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AS MUCH BECAUSE MY
COMPANY IN EMERYVILLE CALIFORNIA
SERVICES THE BAY AREA.
ARM.
WELL WE ARE NOT AS LARGE OF AN
INDUSTRY IS LOS ANGELES IT IS
VERY IMPORTANT TO THOSE OF US
WHO WORK IN IT EVERYDAY I AM WE
DO ACTUALLY HAVE A VERY THRIVING.
SMALLER BUT PASSIONATE COMMUNITY
IN THE BAY AREA.
I REPRESENT A NUMBER OF
TECHNICIANS A NUMBER OF PEOPLE
THAT WORK IN MY SHOP MY COMPANY
IS VERY SMALL COMPANY WAS
STARTED ABOUT THIRTY YEARS AGO.
BY A TRIO OF MOTION PICTURE AND
COMMERCIAL KAFIRS KAFIRS OF THE
CHIEF LIGHTING TECHNICIANS.
THAT HAD SOME GEAR AND DECIDED
HEY YOU GUYS WANNA GET TOGETHER
AND START YOU KNOW MAKING MOVIES
AND STUFF AND OVER THE COURSE OF
THE LAST THIRTY YEARS WE'VE BEEN
INVOLVED. IN ALMOST EVERY MAJOR
AND A LOT OF MINOR PRODUCTIONS
THAT COME THROUGH THE BAY AREA
THIS INCLUDES A LOT OF STUFF
THAT YOU GUYS HAVE PROBABLY SEEN
THE CHRIS COLUMBUS MOVIES OF THE
NINETIES. ARE LATELY IT'S BEEN
DISASTER MOVIES IT SEEMS LIKE
EVERYONE WANTS TO DESTROY SAN
FRANCISCO ON FILM. ARE WHAT WAS
FRUSTRATING UNTIL A COUPLE YEARS
AGO IS THAT WHILE THEY WERE
USING WONDERFUL COMPUTER
GRAPHICS TO DESTROY OUR CITY
THEY WERE ACTUALLY SHOOTING
PORTIONS OF THAT IN.
PRIMARILY VANCOUVER OR LOUISIANA
OR ANY OTHER PLACE THAT WOULD
HAVE A MORE LUCRATIVE TAX
INCENTIVE.
SO WHAT THEY WOULD DO IS THEY
COME TO OUR CITY FOR ABOUT TWO
DAYS WHICH WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR
THAT WORK TO.
TWO DAY SHOOT PLATE SHOTS
BACKGROUND SHOTS AND THEN THEY
WOULD SHOOT THE REST OF IT
SOMEWHERE ELSE FOR THE TAX
INCENTIVES WERE BETTER.
NOW IN THE LAST FOUR YEARS SINCE
EIGHTEEN THIRTY NINE PASSED WE
HAVE SEEN AN INCREASE IN THE
AMOUNT OF PRODUCTION THAT'S COME
TO OUR AREA.
AND MORE IMPORTANTLY THE
QUALITY OF THAT IN THAT THEY'RE
NOT COMING FOR A DAY OR TWO
THEY'RE COMING FOR WEEKS IF NOT
MONTHS IN FACT.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN WE HAD
TWO FULL LENGTH SERIES IN THE
BAY AREA.
THAT BEING THIRTEEN REASONS WHY
AND CHANTS AND THINK CHANCES
AROUND ANYMORE BUT THIRTEEN
REASONS ABOUT AARON AND
COUPLE WEEKS THE SECOND SEASON.
.
WHAT THAT'S DONE TO US OBVIOUSLY
IT'S AN INCREASE IN THE WORK NOW
MY COMPANY MAKES MOST OF ITS
MONEY FROM COMMERCIALS AND PHOTO
SHOOTS AND LIKE THAT AND STUFF
LIKE THAT?
VIS MAJOR PRODUCTIONS WHEN THEY
COME TO TOWN OR VITAL TO US
BECAUSE THEY PROVIDE US AN
OPPORTUNITY TO. TRAIN NEW
MEMBERS OF OUR STAFF TO UPDATE
OUR INVENTORY AND IN AN INDUSTRY
THAT.
THE LIGHTING TOOLS ARE CHANGING
EVERY MONTH NOT EVERY YEAR NOW
WITH LEDS.
IT'S CRUCIAL THAT WE HAVE THESE
LITTLE CERTAIN NOT SURPLUS IS A
FUNDS BUT THESE LITTLE BUMPS AND
OUR INCOME THROUGHOUT THE YEAR
THE COMES FROM THESE LARGE
PRODUCTIONS THAT DIRECTLY TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE INCENTIVES.
ARE NOW A PHENOMENON THAT HAS
HAPPENED IS AS LA COMPANIES NOT
BEING THAT FAR AWAY HAVE COME UP.
AND THERE STARTED TO MOVE IN BUT
I WOULD SAY THERE'S BEEN A NET
GAIN CONSIDERABLY BECAUSE OF
THIS. AND IN GENERAL THAT THE
THE LARGEST THING I CAN'T OVER
EMPHASIZE THIS ENOUGH IS THAT.
VIS PRODUCTIONS EVEN IF FOR ONLY
DOING A PORTION OF IT MY OWN
COMPANIES ONLY GETTING A LITTLE
PIECE OF THAT A THAT'S
APPRECIATED BUT WHAT IT DOES IS
MAINTAIN A CREW BASE IN THE BAY
AREA WHICH IS IMPORTANT WITHOUT
A CREW BASE. NONE OF THESE
PROJECTS ARE GOING TO COME THERE
AND A COMPANY LIKE MINE CANNOT
EXIST SO EVEN IF FOR ONLY
GETTING A PORTION OF THESE
DIRECT INCENTIVE RELATED
PRODUCTIONS.
THE RESULT OF THEM BEING IN OUR
AREA IS ABSOLUTELY INVALUABLE TO
MAINTAINING A CREW BASE AND
WITHOUT THAT A COMPANY LIKE MINE
CANNOT EXIST.
I SUPPORT AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY
FOUR AND I'D LIKE TO URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT AS WELL SO THAT. A
LITTLE BUSINESS SUCH AS MINE AND
MY FIFTEEN TO TWENTY EMPLOYEES
IN THE ONES THAT WE EMPLOY WHEN
WE SWELLED UP TO THE DUTIES
PRODUCTIONS. THINKING TO TO
CONTINUE TO THRIVE IN CALIFORNIA
AND SO THAT THE BAY AREA CAN
ALSO CONTINUE TO HAVE A THRIVING
PRODUCTION COMMUNITY I THINK YOU.
THANK YOU LAST WITNESS.
YOU.
I OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
HE'S JUST YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION.
MANAGER MEMBERS MIKE MONEY GOING
TO BE HALF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS A SPECIFICALLY IBEW
LOCALS FORTY AND FORTY FIVE IN
SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MISSY
JOHNSON ON BEHALF OF THE
DIRECTORS GUILD OF AMERICA IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PAUL OF THE PRESIDENT OF FILM LA
THE FILM OFFICE FOR TWENTY TWO
JURISDICTIONS IN LOS ANGELES AND
ORANGE COUNTIES. IN SUPPORT.
AND SHE WAY CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN SUPPORT.
KATHY GARMENTS THE ENTERTAINMENT
UNION COALITION ALL THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY UNIONS
AND GUILDS IN SUPPORT.
KERRY WOULD SAG AFTRA WE HAVE
EIGHTY THOUSAND MEMBERS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MELISSA PATAK MOTION PICTURE
ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA IN STRONG
SUPPORT ALONG WITH OUR MEMBER
COMPANIES DISNEY AND FOX WHO
CANNOT BE HERE IN PERSON WANTED
NOTED ON THE RECORD THERE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANOTHER GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA TRAVEL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
LUCY STEPHENSON AT THE PHONE
COMMISSION IN SUPPORT.
DOUG BONY WITH THE I A TO SEE
LOCAL EIGHT EIGHT FOR THE STUDIO
TEACHERS AND WELFARE WORKERS IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
DOING HER IE TNC LOCAL EIGHT
HUNDRED THE ART DIRECTORS GUILD
IN SUPPORT.
MATT BROUGHT HERE ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS PUBLIC
AFFAIRS COUNCIL IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS SYLVIA
SOLELY SHAUN BEHALF OF CITY OF
LOS ANGELES MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI
IN SUPPORT. ALSO ON BEHALF OF
THE BOARD OF SPAM SORRY THE CITY
AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO AND
THE OFFICE OF MAYOR MARK FARRELL
IN SUPPORT. ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF SANTA MONICA AS WELL AS
ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS OF PLASTER COUNTY
ALL IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON REBECCA ROMIJN
INTERNATIONAL CINEMATOGRAPHERS
GUILD IATSE LOCAL SIX HUNDRED IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SCOTT BERNARD EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF AYE TNC LOCAL SIX NINE FIVE
PRODUCTION SOUND AND VIDEO
ENGINEERS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ANTHONY POLLOCK I TIAS SEE LOCAL
FORTY FOUR STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
SCOTT GEORGE IATSE LOCAL SEVEN
HUNDRED EDITORS GUILD AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
HI THERE HIDING CAMARA ITUC
LOCAL EIGHT SEVEN ONE IN VERY
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON REGULAR ROMANOW A
COSTUME DESIGNERS GUILD IE TOC
LOCAL EIGHT NINETY TWO. IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
HI I AM MONICA LEVENSON I MEAN
INDEPENDENT PRODUCER AND WITH
THE COMPANY CLTURE OF HANS
PICTURES WHICH IS INDEPENDENT
PRODUCER AND FINANCE COMPANY AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CARLA SALES WARNER BROTHERS
ENTERTAINMENT AND STRONG SUPPORT.
KATHLEEN SERRANO ON BEHALF OF
THE UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA STERN SCHOOL OF MUSIC
AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CAPITALIST WITH NBC UNIVERSAL IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
BOB DENNY LOCAL SEVEN TWENTY
NINE SET PAINTERS AND SIGN
WRITERS IN SUPPORT.
AT DUFFY TEAMSTERS LOCAL THREE
NINETY NINE AND THAT VERY STRONG
SUPPORT.
GRAMLEY CVS CORPORATION AND
SHOWTIME NETWORKS STRUNG WITH OR.
JOANNE DESMOND IATSE LOCAL
SIXTEEN SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA
IN SUPPORT.
ROXANA BACK VOMITING ON BEHALF
OF THE AMERICAN FEDERATION OF
MUSIC MUSICIANS LOCAL FORTY
SEVEN STRONG EXPERT.
DID JOHNELLIS JUNIOR EXECUTIVE
BOARD MEMBER LOCAL WAITING GRIP
I GOT.
AND THAT WASN'T SUPPORT A TOM
DAVIS CALIFORNIA TNC ACCOUNTS ON
THE SUPPORT.
ALEX ARGUE I WOULD LABORS LOCAL
SEVEN TWENTY FOUR IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
IT'S NEVER CORBIN ON BEHALF OF
THE COW FOR A TOUCH OF
ASSOCIATION WE BEEN IN
CONVERSATION WITH THE AUTHORS
OFFICE AND APPRECIATE BACKGROUND
YOU'VE SENT ON ON CERTAINLY
THERE ARE SOME BENEFITS TO THIS
TAX CREDIT. I WOULD JUST
ENCOURAGE THE BODY AND AS YOU'RE
CONSIDERING THIS MEASURE
CONSIDER NOT ONLY THIS MEASURE
BUT ALL OF THE OTHER MEASURES
BEFORE YOU CERTAINLY THERE ARE.
IMPLICATIONS ON PROP NINETY
EIGHT HERE IN THIS MEASURE ON
THERE HAVE BEEN OBVIOUSLY
PREVIOUS ITERATIONS OF THIS TAX
CREDIT ON THE IMPACT THE ABILITY
TO DELIVER SERVICES IN OUR
PUBLIC SCHOOLS. AND IN SPITE OF
THE MAYOR OF THE GOVERNOR
ANNOUNCING IN THE MAY REVISE A
SIX BILLION DOLLAR SURPLUS
THEY'RE CURRENTLY A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE MEASURES RELATED TO
TAX EXPENDITURES AND CREDITS
MOVING THROUGH THIS BODY RIGHT
NOW. MORE THAN DOUBLE THE AMOUNT
OF THE SURPLUS SO I WOULD JUST
ENCOURAGE YOU TO CONSIDER THAT
AS YOU VOTE ON THESE MEASURES I
APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORTS TO
TAILOR THAT'S ON BUT AGAIN WE DO
SO HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT PROP
NINETY EIGHT THINK.
I CAN COME BACK.
SO DO YOU HAVE YOUR WILL
WHICHEVER POSITION.
AT WITH IT WE HAVE OUTSTANDING
CONCERNS AT THIS POINT REGARDING
THE IMPACT ON PROP NINETY EIGHT
OF THE MEASURE. OF HIM MOVING
FORWARD IF WE CAN GET A LETTER
FROM YOU.
I THINK IT.
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE TALKED BURKE.
BOB.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CALDERON I THANK
YOU FOR THE REVISIONS TO AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
BLOOM THANK YOU FOR THE
REVISIONS.
WITH THOSE REVISIONS I FEEL I
CAN SUPPORT YOUR BILL AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SCENE NINE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
WE JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
WE DO NOT HAVE A QUORUM APPLE
ONLY DO I JUST WANNA MAKE A
QUICK COMMENT MY.
.
MY DAUGHTER'S FATHER ACTUALLY IS
AYE ON SEE AND WE SPENT THE LAST
TEN YEARS WATCHING THE
DIFFERENCE WE SAW THE YEARS WENT
ON NOT UNLIKE YOU OUR FAMILY WAS
ALL TOGETHER AND THEN THE YEARS
WHEN HE HAD TO LEAVE AND SPEND A
LOT OF TIME IN NEW ORLEANS AND.
PLACES LIKE THAT.
AND IT'S CHALLENGING FOR NOT
JUST WORKERS BUT FOR THEIR
FAMILIES SO WITH THAT WHEN WE DO
HAVE A QUORUM THE RECOMMENDATION
IS TO PASS
APPROPRIATE TO APPROPRIATION THE
COMMANDER
.
I'M LIVING A FILE ITEM TWELVE.
AB THIRTY SEVENTY TWO.
MISTER CHIU WOULD YOU LIKE TO
OPEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
COLLEAGUES A. B. THIRTY SEVENTY
TWO WOULD INCREASE OUR STATES
AFFORDABLE HOUSING TAX CREDIT BY
THREE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS.
THIS TAX CREDIT PROGRAM HAS BEEN
INCREDIBLY SUCCESSFUL IN THE
PAST AND IN TURN WOULD LEVERAGE
ANOTHER ONE BILLION DOLLARS IN
FEDERAL TAX CREDITS LOCAL AND
PRIVATE SECTOR INVESTMENTS. THIS
BILL IS ALMOST IDENTICAL TO MY
A. B. THIRTY FIVE BILL FROM THE
LAST SESSION AND I WANT TO THANK
EVERY MEMBER FROM THE ASSEMBLY.
OF FROM THE LAST SESSION WHO
VOTED FOR IT REPUBLICAN AND
DEMOCRAT.
WELL LAST YEAR WE MADE REAL
HEADWAY ON HOUSING THE RECENT
TRUMP TAX CUT IN THE FEDERAL
CORPORATE TAX RATE FROM THIRTY
FIVE TO TWENTY ONE PERCENT. HAS
HAD A SIGNIFICANT NEGATIVE
IMPACT ON OUR STATE'S AFFORDABLE
HOUSING INVESTMENTS
TO THE TUNE OF REDUCING OUR FOR
DOUBLE RENTAL PRODUCTION BY
ALMOST FIFTY THOUSAND RENTAL
HOMES A YEAR. AND ONE POINT
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS IN LOCAL
STATE AND FEDERAL TAXES.
IN ADDITION TO INCREASING THE
SIZE OF OUR PROGRAM ARE BILL
ALSO ELIMINATES THE CAP ON
INDIVIDUAL TAXPAYERS WHO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE CREDIT WHICH IN
TURN FURTHER INCREASES THE VALUE
OF THE PROGRAM TO INVESTORS.
GIVEN THE MAGNITUDE OF THE
HOUSING CRISIS AND THE ONE POINT
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR WE
LOST WITH THE ELIMINATION OF
REDEVELOPMENT IN THE TRYING UP
OF HOUSING BOND MONIES. IT'S
CRITICAL THAT WE EXPAND THIS TAX
CREDIT AND LEVERAGE ANOTHER
BILLION DOLLARS WITH THIS THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT. I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR INPUT AND I
WILL ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS TO DO THE FOLLOWING
SUNSET THIS.
PROPOSED THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR A INCREASE IN THE TAX
CREDIT AFTER FIVE YEARS REQUIRE
INDIVIDUAL TAXPAYERS TO PAY A
DOLLAR FOR EACH TAX CREDIT. AND
SUNSET THE ELIMINATION OF THE
CAP ON INDIVIDUAL TAXPAYERS
PURCHASING THIS TAX CREDIT AFTER
FIVE YEARS.
AND WITHOUT A LIKE TO TURN IT
OVER TO OUR WITNESS.
I'M KEVIN WILSON WITH ANOTHER
CRACKING COMPANY WE ARE.
NOT ON YOUR MICROPHONE IS NOT
WORKING.
THERE SWITCHED I THINK IT'S
WORKING NOW.
I MOVEMENT TELLS WILSON I'M A
CPA WITH THE ACCOUNTING FIRM
NOBLE GRAPHIC AND COMPANY.
HOW WE SPECIALIZE IN?
LARA AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT IN THE.
BUT WE DO A LOT OF WORK WITH THE
FEDERAL TAX CREDIT NOW WE'RE
VERY FAMILIAR WITH THE. NEW
FEDERAL TAX REFORM BILL AS.
MISTER CHIU MENTIONED THE.
FEDERAL REDUCTION OF THE
CORPORATE TAX RATE WILL
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE.
THE FUTURE SUPPLY OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA.
ALLOWING INDIVIDUAL INVESTORS
TO UTILIZE THIS STATE LOW INCOME
HOUSING TAX CREDIT. COULD
GENERATE ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
TO OFFSET THESE LOSSES ARE AND
INCREASE THE PROGRAM FISHING T.
BY UPWARD BY UP TO FIFTY PERCENT.
ELIMINATION OF THE SALT
PRODUCTION.
AND THE FEDERAL TAX REFORM BILL.
COULD RESULT IN THE CALIFORNIA.
LOW INCOME HOUSING TAX CREDIT
HAVING THE POTENTIAL TO CREATE
SIGNIFICANT ADDITIONAL VALUE TO
INDIVIDUALS BECAUSE. INDIVIDUALS
ARE NOT.
.
LOSING.
A STATE DEDUCTION IN. THIRD
LOWERING THEIR. THEIR CORPORATE.
THERE THEIR STATE INCOME TAX
LIABILITY WITHOUT RECOGNIZING A
CORRESPONDING INCREASE IN THEIR
FEDERAL TAX LIABILITY.
SO.
AS A RESULT OF THAT YOU KNOW WE
COULD SEE INDIVIDUAL INVESTORS
PAYING UPWARDS OF A DOLLAR PER
EACH.
DOLLAR OF TAX CREDIT WHERE IS
RIGHT NOW THE CORPORATE
INVESTORS.
ARE PAYING MAYBE AROUND EIGHTY
CENTS
PER CREDIT BECAUSE THEY
RECOGNIZE A CORRESPONDING
INCREASE IN THEIR FEDERAL TAX
LIABILITY BECAUSE THERE.
THE STATE INCOME TAX DEDUCTION.
IS IS REDUCED ON THEIR FEDERAL
TAX RETURN.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
A MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MARIN
HIGGINS REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING CONSORTIUM IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THE.
LOW INCOME HOUSING TAX CREDIT
PROGRAMS ON THE PRIMARY BUILDING%
PROGRAMS FOR AFFORDABLE RENTAL
HOUSING IN THE STATE. THIS BILL
NOT ONLY INCREASES THE TAX
CREDIT BUT IT MAKES IT MORE
WORKABLE SO THAT WE CAN BET
WOULD SO THAT WE DO NOT LEAVE A
FEDERAL TAX SUBSIDY ON THE ON
THE TABLE. IN THE TEAR IN THE
FORM OF TAX EXEMPT BONDS WHICH
CAN WORK WITH FOUR PERCENT
CREDIT SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE
URGE STRONG SUPPORT A BILL.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS SILVIUS
ALICIA ON BEHALF OF THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO IN THE
OFFICE OF MAYOR MARK PARENTS
TRANSPORT THINKING.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NINE COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEN IT WOULD YOU LIKE CLOSE.
AGAIN I APPRECIATE THE WORK OF
THE COMMITTEE AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
WE ARE STILL SUBCOMMITTEE BUT I
DO OF THE ACTION WILL BE TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS AND
THANK YOU FOR BEING THE MAN.
IN YOUR OPENING PUSH IT THANK
YOU.
LIVING TO FILE ITEM ELEVEN A. B.
THIRTY TWENTY NINE DOCTOR
ARAMBULA WOULD YOU LIKE TO OPEN.
FREAK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
TODAY I PRESENTE B. THIRTY
TWENTY NINE WHICH LOOKS TO
CREATE A NEW CALIFORNIA HIRING
TAX CREDIT.
LET ME BEGIN BY SAYING THAT I
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
IN TWENTY THIRTEEN THE
LEGISLATURE ADOPTED SEVERAL
BILLS WHICH CREATED THE EXISTING
CALIFORNIA HIGHER TAX CREDIT.
THIS TAX CREDIT HAS BEEN
SIGNIFICANTLY UNDER UTILIZED AND
A. B. THIRTY TWENTY NINE LOOKS
TO CHANGE THAT.
THE GOAL IS TO ALLOW MORE
EMPLOYERS TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THIS TAX CREDIT AND TO CREATE
JOBS FOR CALIFORNIANS WHO MAY
STRUGGLE TO FIND WORK DUE TO
THEIR PERSONAL HISTORY.
LONG TERM UNEMPLOYED.
VETERANS EX OFFENDERS RECIPIENTS
OF CAL WORKS OR GENERAL
ASSISTANCE
AND RECIPIENTS OF THE FEDERAL
EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT. WOULD
BE QUALIFIED FULL TIME EMPLOYEES
UNDER THE SPELL.
WHICH IS THE SAME UNDER THE
CURRENT HIRING TAX CREDIT.
AB THIRTY TWENTY NINE LOOKS TO
BE AN EXPANSION OF THE EXISTING
NEW EMPLOYMENT CREDIT. IT WOULD
EXPAND THE EXISTING CREDIT IN
SEVERAL WAYS.
BY GEOGRAPHY.
INDUSTRY AND RANGE OF QUALIFIED
WAGES.
THIS NEW CREDIT WOULD BE
AVAILABLE STARTING JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY NINETEEN AND WOULD BE A
THIRTY FIVE PERCENT RATE OF
QUALIFIED WAGES SAME AS THE
CURRENT CREDIT.
SPENDING THIS TYPE OF HIRING
INCENTIVES FOR CALIFORNIANS
STRUGGLED TO FIND WORK IS GOOD
FOR BUSINESS.
GOOD FOR EMPLOYEES AND GOOD FOR
THE ECONOMY.
IN ESSENCE PART.
THIS IS IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING IT NINE AYE COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE DARK ARAMBULA TO A
CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
WILL WE HAVE A QUORUM IT'S THE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO PASS THEM AND
IT APPROPRIATIONS.
I THINK YOU.
WOMEN FILE ITEM TO A BE
SEVENTEEN FORTY EIGHT MISTER
STEINORTH WOULD YOU LIKE TO OPEN.
NO PROBLEM.
AND. THIS MISTER PATTERSON YOU
ARE PRESENT FILE ITEM FIVE AB
TWENTY TWO FIFTY NINE
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY OF UP PRESENTING AB
TWENTY TWO FIFTY NINE AND ALSO
WELL. THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR IN
THE STAFF AND OTHERS FOR WORKING
OUT WITH ME ON THIS WE
APPRECIATE IT VERY VERY MUCH
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR THAT.
THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE PARENTS
WHO HAVE EXPERIENCED A
STILLBIRTH. WITH A TAX CREDIT OF
UP TO TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
ASSIST WITH THE ASSOCIATED
MEDICAL VERY A COSTS AND OTHER
COSTS OF A STILLBORN CHILD.
A STILL BIRTH IS THE DEATH OR
LOSS OF THE BABY AFTER TWENTY
WEEKS OF PREGNANCY. AND CAN
OCCUR UP BEFOREOR DURING
DELIVERY ABOUT TWENTY SIX
THOUSAND BABIES ARE STILL BORN
IN THE UNITED STATES. WHICH IS
MORE THAN TEN TIMES AS MANY
DEATHS AS THE NUMBER THAT OCCUR
FROM SINCE.
IN MOST CASES PARENTS WHO
EXPERIENCED A STILLBIRTH A MADE
PREPARATIONS FOR THAT TRIAL BY
BUT CRIBS DIAPERS HELL BABY
SHOWERS ALL OF THAT WITH FRIENDS
FAMILY EVEN THOUGH. THEY VERY
WELL MAY HAVE CARRIED THAT THE
BABY PASSED THE DUE DATE. THAT
BABY WAS BORN WITHOUT A HEART
BEAT EVEN STILL THE MEDICAL
COSTS FOR STILLBIRTH ARE HIGHER.
THAN THOSE OF A LIVE BIRTH THESE
PARENTS THEN HAVE TO ENDURE A
CONSIDERABLE FINANCIAL HARDSHIPS
WITH RESPECT TO MEDICAL EXPENSES.
FUNERAL ARRANGEMENTS AND GRIEF
COUNSELING.
THIS BILL WILL ASSIST PARENTS
WITH ALL OF THOSE UNEXPECTED
COSTS DURING A TIME WHEN THEY
NEED IT MOST.
OF THIS BILL CANNOT TAKE AWAY
THE LOS THEY'VE EXPERIENCED BUT
IT CAN PROVIDE RELIEF FOR
FAMILIES AT THIS MOMENT IN NEED.
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL I HAVE WITH ME TODAY MR
GAVIN FERGUSON HE AND HIS WIFE
WERE FOUNDERS OF THE NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION PHOEBE SPAWNED.
ALSO WITH THIS IS THAT MRS AREA
WEEKS WHO IS THE CHAIR OF THE
LOS ANGELES CHAPTER OF THE STAR
LEGACY FOUNDATION FOR STILL. UP
BORN RESEARCH.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
I THANK YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
FOR ALLOWING ME TO BE HERE TODAY
TO TELL YOU WHY I SUPPORT AB TWO
TWO FIVE NINE.
THANK YOU ALSO REPRESENTATIVE
PATTERSON FOR GIVING ME THIS
OPPORTUNITY AND BRINGING SUCH A
NEEDED BILL THE CALIFORNIA.
MY NAME IS KEVIN FERGUSON I'M A
MORNING RADIO SHOW HOST HERE IN
SACRAMENTO IN ONE A SIX POINT
FIVE THE AND. MY DAUGHTER PHOEBE
WAS DUE ON AUGUST SIXTH TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN.
PHOEBE HAVE A TOTALLY NORMAL
PREGNANCY OUR DOCTOR OFTEN JOKED
THAT SHE WAS READING THE
TEXTBOOK IN THEIR.
THE DUE DATE CAME AND WENT AND
WE ANXIOUSLY. WAITED FOR HER TO
SHOW SIGNS THAT SHE WAS READY TO
COME OUT.
ON AUGUST ELEVENTH WE WENT IN
FOR A ROUTINE APPOINTMENT. AND
TO DISCUSS WHEN WE WOULD INDUCE
WE JOKE WITH THE DOCTOR. WHEN HE
CAME AND BUT WHEN THE DOCTOR HAD
TROUBLE FINDING PHOEBE'S
HEARTBEAT ALL JOKING STOPPED.
AFTER SEARCHING FOR ALMOST A
MINUTE.
HE FINALLY HER HEART BEAT
EVERYONE IN THE ROOM THREE AT
THE SIGH OF RELIEF BUT THE
DOCTOR STILL LOOKED NERVOUS.
HE TOOK MY WIFE'S WRIST
ENCOUNTERED HER PULSE AND SAID
THAT WHEN HE WAS PICKING UP WAS
HER HEART BE AND NOT THE BABY'S.
HE QUICKLY PULLED HER OVER TO
ANOTHER ROOM WITH AN ULTRASOUND
AND STARTED TO LOOK AT OUR
DAUGHTER.
AS SOON AS HE HAD HER ON THE
SCREEN WE ALL COULD SEE HER
LITTLE HEART WAS NO LONGER
BEATING.
HE THEN LOOKED AT US AND SAID
THE WORST WORDS THAT ANYONE
COULD SAY TO A PERSON.
I'M SORRY BUT YOUR BABY IS DIED.
WE WERE AT FORTY WEEKS
WE'RE ACTUALLY PASSED FORTY
WEEKS.
EVERYTHING WAS FINE UP TO THAT
POINT THERE IS.
SCREAMING AND CRYING FROM US FOR
MONTHS
AND I'LL SPARE YOU THE DETAILS
BUT NO THAT THE LEVEL OF GRIEF
FELT FROM PARENTS WHO NEVER GET
TO HOLD THEIR BABY. HAVE THEM
LEAVE THE HOSPITAL WITH NOTHING
IN THEIR ARMS LIVE IN A HOUSE
WITH AN EMPTY NURSERY THAT THEY
BUILT IS A PAIN THAT NO ONE IS
EQUIPPED TO HANDLE AND OFTEN
SWALLOWS COUPLES HOLE.
THIS IS WHY AB TWO TWO FIVE NINE
IS SO IMPORTANT.
SEE IT'S NOT BAD ENOUGH THAT
PARENTS HAVE TO SURF THE WAVES
OF GRIEF FOR THE REST OF THEIR
LIVES MORNING A CHILD THAT THEY
WILL NEVER GET TO WATCH GROW UP.
THEY ALSO HAVE TO DEAL WITH
UNEXPECTED EXPENSES THAT ADD
INSULT TO INJURY.
FUNERAL COSTS.
BURIAL OR CREMATION COSTS.
WORKING AFTER SOMETHING LIKE
THIS IS IMPOSSIBLE SO THERE IS A
LACK OF INCOME IN SOME CASES.
SOME COUPLES NEED TO LEAVE THEIR
HOUSE OUR TOWN FOR A BIT IN
ORDER TO COLLECT THEIR THOUGHTS
AND BE ALONE.
THERAPY IS ESSENTIAL WHEN IT
COMES TO MANAGING NOT ONLY GRIEF
BUT POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS
AND IT IS OFTEN NOT COVERED BY
INSURANCE AND FINALLY THE MOST
ROBUST MEDICAL EXPENSES.
TO PAY FOR THE BIRTH OF A BABY
THAT YOU NOW HAVE TO BURY.
OVER THE PAST SEVERAL DECADES IN
FOR MORTALITY. HAS SUCCESSFULLY
DECLINED HOWEVER STILL BIRTHS
HAVE NOT.
THEIR MYSTERIOUS AND WHAT CAUSES
THEM IS A NUMBER OF HIDDEN
DANGERS.
THE TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN OUR
DAUGHTER PHOEBE ELAINE FERGUSON
WAS ONE OF TWENTY SIX THOUSAND
STILL BIRTH IN AMERICA.
IT'S FAR MORE COMMON THAN PEOPLE
REALIZE AND PARENTS OF THOSE
TWENTY SIX THOUSAND BORN STILL
EVERY YEAR NEED HELP.
MY WIFE AND I ARE VERY LUCKY
PEOPLE WE WERE ABLE TO HANDLE
ALL THOSE EXPENSES BUT WE KNOW
MANY PEOPLE WHO COULDN'T. AND
HAD TO CHOOSE WHICH CRUCIAL
HEALING EXPERIENCE THEY WERE
GOING TO BYPASS BECAUSE THAT.
DOZENS Y. WE STARTED A CHARITY
CALLED PHOEBE SPAWNED.
WHICH AIMS TO OFFER GRANTS TO
COUPLES WHO SUFFERED A
MISCARRIAGE OR STILLBIRTH. SO
THAT THEY CAN STILL GET THE
GRIEF THERAPY THAT SO HELPFUL.
MANY PARENTS LIKE I SUFFER FROM
PTSD AND OTHER FORMS OF PSYCHIC
TRAUMA AND MOST INSURANCE
COMPANIES DON'T COVER THE
COUNSELING NEEDED TO HELP WITH
THIS.
BECAUSE THERE'S NO FINANCIAL
HELP FOR US WE THOUGHT.
WE'D HELP THE SAME WAY THE
REPRESENTATIVE PATTERSON IS
TRYING TO HELP AND RELIEVE SOME
OF THE FINANCIAL PRESSURE.
DEALING WITH THE LOSS OF A CHILD
THE WAY THAT WE HAVE BEEN SO
MANY OTHERS HAVE HAD TO DO. IS
THE WORST THING A PERSON CAN GO
THROUGH SELL WHATEVER ANYONE CAN
DO TO MAKE IT LESS TERRIBLE IS A
BLESSING.
YOU ALL HAVE THE POWER TO DO
THAT.
PEOPLE LIKE US KNOW THAT NOTHING
WILL EVER BRING OUR PHOEBE BACK
BUT KNOWING THAT PEOPLE WANT TO
HELP AND WILL NEVER FORGET HER
IS MORE HEALING THE MOST REALIZE.
NO GRIEVING PARENT SHOULD HAVE
TO WORRY ABOUT MONEY AFTER
LOSING THEIR CHILD AND WHILE
TRYING SO HARD NOT TO LOSE
THEMSELVES.
I ANCHORED YOU TO PLEASE APPROVE
AB TWO TWO FIVE NINE AND DO WHAT
YOU CAN FOR PEOPLE LIKE ME AND
MY WIFE.
AN EFFORT LIKE THIS GOES MUCH
MUCH FURTHER THAN YOU THINK AND
CAN BE SOMETHING THAT HELPS IN A
TIME WHEN THESE PEOPLE FEEL
HELPLESS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE WHAT
OTHER WITNESSES AND SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ARIEL WEEKS
AND I'M THE CHAIR OF THE LOS
ANGELES CHAPTER THE STAR LEGACY
FOUNDATION. WE ARE THE LEADING
NATIONAL COMMUNITY OF HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS FAMILIES
RESEARCHERS POLICYMAKERS AND
ADVOCATES DEDICATED TO HEALTHY
PREGNANCY OUTCOMES AND
STILLBIRTH PREVENTION.
I AM MOTHER TO SYDNEY AND FIDDLY
FINLEY WERE VENTO'S.
AT FIVE A. M. ON AUGUST
FIFTEENTH TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
AT FORTY ONE WEEKS PREGNANT.
MY HUSBAND AND I ENTERED LABOR
AND DELIVERY WITH CONTRACTIONS
THAT WERE FIVE MINUTES APART.
WE WERE THRILLED AND EXCITED TO
MEET OUR FIRST DAUGHTER SYDNEY
MARIE AND REALIZE ALL OF OUR
DREAMS FROM THE LAST TEN MONTHS
ABOUT OUR FUTURE FAMILY.
IN THE FIRST FEW MINUTES OF
TRIAGE. THEY TURNED TO US AND
SAID I'M SORRY BUT THERE'S NO
HEARTBEAT.
IN THAT MOMENT WE BECAME A
STATISTIC IN AN EPIDEMIC THAT NO
ONE SPEAKS ABOUT.
ONE OF TWENTY SIX THOUSAND
FAMILIES WHO SUFFER A STILLBIRTH
IN THE U. S. EVERY YEAR.
BASICALLY THE EQUIVALENT TO A
SEVEN FORTY SEVEN CRASHING EVERY
FIVE DAYS.
THIS IS A STATISTIC THAT HAS NOT
CHANGED IN FIFTY YEARS.
WE DELIVERED SYDNEY BY SEE
SECTION A FEW HOURS LATER TO A
SILENT ROOM.
THE DAYS THAT FOLLOWED BROUGHT
US IN DIGNITY AFTER AND DIGNITY.
I STAYED IN RECOVERY AT CEDARS
FOR THREE DAYS IN THE MATERNITY
WARD LISTENING TO LIVING BABIES
CRY IN THE ROOMS AROUND ME.
THEY TAPED A LEAF TO OUR DOOR SO
HOSPITAL STAFF WERE ALERTED
BEFORE ENTERING THAT WE'VE LOST
A BABY.
NURSES WHISPERED ABOUT ME AND
DOCTORS AVOIDED US COMPLETELY.
AFTER I RELEASE MY HUSBAND WILL
BE EMPTY HANDED OUT OF THE
HOSPITAL.
I SAT ON THE CURB TO WAIT FOR
HIM TO PICK UP OUR CAR THAT HELD
ARE PROFESSIONALLY INSTALLED
USELESS INFANT CARSEAT.
AT HOME WE FACED A MAUSOLEUM
NURSERY FILLED WITH FRESHLY
WASHED CLOTHES TS
EXPENSIVE FURNITURE THAT WERE
WELL PAST OF THE RETURN WINDOW.
LIKE ANY OTHER MOTHER MY MILK
CAME IN AND MY BODY BLED POST
SURGERY FOR SIX WEEKS.
SOON FRIENDS AND FAMILY VISITS
DRIED UP AND MY EMPLOYER
INFORMED ME THAT MY SIX YEARS OF
SERVICE TO THEM WERE OUT A
CONCLUSION.
PERHAPS THEY DIDN'T NEED ME
ANYMORE BUT I THINK I JUST
BUMPED THEM OUT.
JUST LIKE EVERY PARENT AFTER THE
DELIVERY WE OWE THE HOSPITAL FOR
MY ANASTASIA. MY ACTUAL SURGERY
THE RECOVERY STATE AND ALL
RELATED COST.
WE EVEN PAID OUR BIRTH DO LET
CASSIE CHERNEY TWELVE HUNDRED
FIFTY DOLLARS IN ADVANCE FOR
LABOR WE NEVER GOT TO SEE.
SHE REFUSED TO REFUND US STATING
THAT WE DIDN'T GIVE TWO WEEKS
CANCELLATION NOTICE PER OUR
AGREEMENT.
WE OWED OUR OBSTETRICIAN OVER
TWELVE HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR
DELIVERING SYDNEY'S LIFELESS
BODY.
AND UNLIKE THE PARENT OF A LIVE
BIRTH WE WOULD ALSO OWE TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS JUST FOR THE
AUTOPSY THAT WE WOULD NEED TO
PAY OUT OF POCKET.
WE OWED FOR FUNERAL AND
CREMATION EXPENSES COUNSELING
AND WE WOULD NOT BE ELIGIBLE FOR
THE XML A LEAF.
NOT TO MENTION THE COST OF THE
CARE WE RECEIVED WHILE I WAS
PREGNANT WHICH WAS ABOUT A
THOUSAND DOLLARS A MONTH FOR THE
TEN MONTHS.
THROUGH ALL THE ADDICTING HE'S I
FACED IN THE LAST TWO YEARS THE
MOST TRAUMATIZING FOR ME WAS ON
MARCH THIRTY FIRST TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN. WHAT MY HUSBAND AND I
WENT TO OUR ACCOUNTANTS OFFICE
TO COMPLETE OUR TAX RETURN ANY
ASKED AS THE STANDARD QUESTION?
DID YOU GIVE BIRTH IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN. UNFORTUNATELY
WE HAD TO SAY NO.
NO I DIDN'T HAVE SEE SECTION IN
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN NO I WAS
NEVER PREGNANT FIRST FORTY ONE
WEEKS IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
AND NO I DIDN'T AUTOPSY CREMATE
MY FIRST BORN.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA FORCE ME
TO DIE THAT SYDNEY MARIE EVER
EXISTED.
TODAY I'M NOT ASKING YOU FOR
SPECIAL TREATMENT FOR FAMILIES
WHO SUFFER A STILLBIRTH I'M
ASKING FOR EQUAL TREATMENT TO
PARENTS FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO HAVE
HEALTHY LIFE BABIES.
BESIDES PROVIDING A LITTLE
RELIEF TO HELP OFFSET THE
EXPENSE OF A STILL BIRTH WHICH
COSTS MORE THAN A LIVE BIRTH.
YOU WILL BE RESTORING A LITTLE
BIT OF DIGNITY TO THOSE LIKE ME
WHO FEEL AS THOUGH SCIENCE
DOCTORS GOVERNMENT IN THE WORLD
HAVE FORGOTTEN US.
I'M ASKING YOU TO SUPPORT A BILL
THAT WILL NOT BENEFIT ME
PERSONALLY I'M NOT HERE TO FORCE
YOU TO DECIDE IF SAID HE WAS A
BABY OR A FETUS I'M HERE TO TELL
YOU THAT I'M STILL APPARENT.
LIVE BABY OR STILLBIRTH WE ARE
ALL FATHERS WE ARE ALL MOTHERS
WE ARE ALL PARENTS I GAVE BIRTH.
I WOULD HAVE BEEN SO GRATEFUL IF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HADN'T
TURNED ITS BACK ON ME LIKE SO
MANY OF MY FRIENDS FAMILY AND
COWORKERS.
NO PARENT SHOULD EVER HAVE TO
DENY THEIR CHILDREN'S EXISTENCE.
I HOPE YOU ALL HAD A LOVELY
MOTHER'S DAY.
AGAIN I'M ARIEL WEEKS MOTHER OF
TWO EVEN THOUGH I CAN ONLY HOLD
ONE IN MY ARMS.
THINKING.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
HELLO MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MANY MISTER UNDER
GREGORY AND FROM ALL GROWTH I'M
HERE TO SUPPORT AB TWO TWO FIVE
NINE. I PERSONALLY HAVE
EXPERIENCED THE LOSS OF TWO
BABIES
AND A I KNOW FROM MY VOLUNTEER
WORK FOR AN ORGANIZATION CALLED
SHARING PARENTS THAT THERE ARE
MANY OTHER PEOPLE THAT HAVE
EXPERIENCED A STILLBIRTH. THIS
BILL WOULD PROVIDE A LOT OF
SUPPORT FOR THOSE FAMILIES IN
NEED AND FOR THOSE REASONS I
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
I AM DRAPER NOW ON WHAT THE
CATHOLIC CHURCH IN CALIFORNIA
WHERE I AM VERY STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL AS SAYS GOODS HE
ADDED AS HE BEING EVEN STRONGER
WITH A. PROFOUND BELICHICK
PROVISION FOR THOSE WHO ARE POOR.
I VENN UPDATE LETTER.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE MISTER PARIS WOULD
YOU LIKE.
I THINK I APPRECIATE VERY MUCH
THE TESTIMONY HERE OBVIOUSLY OF
THAT.
THE TAX BENEFIT.
CAN'T REALLY BRING BACK.
.
STILLBORN BUT IT CERTAINLY CAN
LIST SOME OF THE LOAD AND SO I
WILL ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
I WANT TO THANK YOU MR KRAUSS
AND I KNOW IT'S TAKEN US A
MINUTE TO GET IT HERE I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
I. AND WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE ON ON THIS MEASURE.
CLEARLY I'M CRYING.
.
AS A MOTHER WHO STRUGGLE TO HAVE
A CHILD MYSELF AND I KNOW THE.
HORRIBLE LOSS OF OF LOSING A
BABY IN TERMS SO.
A.
I'M SORRY YOU'RE HERE I'M SORRY
FOR BOTH YOUR LOSS BUT IF WE CAN
HOPEFULLY LIGHTEN YOUR LOAD IN
ANYWAY AND WE'RE HERE TO DO THAT
SO.
WITHOUT WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM
BUT THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO
PASS TO PREPARATIONS.
THANK YOU SO I DON'T THINK YOU.
MISTER STEINORTH ARE YOU READY.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM TO AB
SEVENTEEN FORTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
TODAY WE'RE HERE TO PRESENT AB
SEVENTEEN FORTY EIGHT WITH MY
COLLEAGUES IN PRINCIPLE CO
AUTHOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOBBY
ARROW.
THIS LEGISLATION TO PROVIDE MUCH
NEEDED REFORMS TO THE
PORTABILITY TAX.
HE IS ME TO PROPERTY TAX
PORTABILITY IN CALIFORNIA BY
GIVING FLEXIBILITY TO
CALIFORNIANS YOUNG AND OLD.
SPECIFICALLY AB SEVENTEEN FORTY
EIGHT WILL IMPROVE PROPERTY TAX
PORTABILITY BY ALLOWING
STATEWIDE TRANSFERS. UNLIMITED
TRANSFERS TO HOMEOWNERS OVER THE
AGE OF FIFTY FIVE A NEW ONE TIME
TRANSPERTH FOR HOMEOWNERS UNDER
FIFTY FIVE AND IMPLEMENT A
BLENDED BASE FOR MORE EXPENSIVE
HOMES.
WE WILL NO LONGER LEVER SENIOR
STUCK IN HOUSING THAT IS TOO BIG
FOR THEM OR FAR AWAY FROM THEIR
FAMILIES BECAUSE LONGTIME
HOMEOWNERS FEAR MASSIVE
FLUCTUATIONS IN THE PROPERTY TAX
BILL.
AND WILL PROVIDE OUR YOUNG
FAMILIES WITH AN INCENTIVE TO
GET INTO THE MARKET EARLY AND
THE OPPORTUNITY TO INVEST IN
THEIR FUTURES BECAUSE
HOMEOWNERSHIP IS THE PATHWAY TO
SUCCESS FOR MIDDLE CLASS
PROSPERITY.
LEGISLATORS HAVE WORKED TOGETHER
TO BRING FORWARD INNOVATIVE
CHANGES TO PROPERTY TAX
PORTABILITY FOR YEARS INCLUDING
LAST YEAR MEASURE PASSED BY THIS
COMMITTEE THAT WOULD ALLOW
STATEWIDE TRANSFERS AND WAS CO
AUTHORED AND SUPPORTED BY
YOURSELF MADAM CHAIR.
WHAT SHIPPING WEIGHT HOUSING
CRISIS IS NOBLE WE HAVE TO MAKE
BIG CHANGES TO MAKE A BIG
DIFFERENCE?
THIS HOUSING STAGNATION ISN'T
GOOD FOR OUR MARKET ECONOMY AND
IT ISN'T GOOD FOR CALIFORNIANS.
WE MUST OPEN THE PATHWAY FROM
HOMEOWNERSHIP TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS AND TODAY I AM
JOINED BY MY COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CABALLERO INTERESTS FOR
CARLISLE FROM CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS.
SOME OF THEM ARE COMING YEAR.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY ON THIS
IMPORTANT BILL WHICH I AM PROUD
TO CO AUTHOR. CALIFORNIA'S
HOUSING CRISIS IT IS NOT A BAR
PART. CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING
CRISIS IS A BIPARTISAN ISSUE AND
ONE THAT WE ALL NEED TO ADDRESS.
I DON'T NEED TO ITERATE THE DIRE
HOUSING SITUATION OUR STATE IS
IN WE ARE ALL AWARE OF THE
CRISIS AND WHAT WHAT IT WILL
TAKE TO GET CALIFORNIA OUT OF
THIS SITUATION.
EVEN WITH ALL OF THE LEGISLATION
PASSED LAST YEAR IT IS ONLY A
DROP IN THE BUCKET AND WE NEED
TO GET CREATIVE. AB SEVENTEEN
FORTY EIGHT DOES JUST THAT.
BY EXPANDING THE PROPERTY TAX
PORTABILITY WE CAN GET EMPTY
NESTERS OUT OF THE BIG HOUSES
AND FREE UP MUCH NEEDED HOUSING
STOCK. FOR YOUNGER FAMILIES MANY
HOUSES OCCUPIED BY IT EMPTY
NESTERS AND SENIOR CITIZENS ARE
TOO BIG.
NEED LOTS OF WORK AND THE
REPAIRS AND UPKEEP CAN OFTEN BE
A BURDEN AND IF YOU'VE EVER DONE
ANY PRECINCT WALKING YOU KNOW
THAT WHEN YOU COME UP TO A HOUSE.
THAT HAS A DRIED UP FRONT LAWN
AND IT LOOKS LIKE IT NEEDS A
GOOD PAINT JOB. AND YOU KNOCK ON
THE DOOR THAT USUALLY A SENIOR
WHO IS DESPERATE FOR SOMEONE TO
COME AND VISIT THEM THEY'LL
INVITE YOU IN IN THEY'VE NEAR
THEY CLOSED ALL THE DOORS DOORS
IN THE HOUSE DOWN IN THEIR
LIVING IN. IN KIND OF THE LIVING
ROOM WATCHING TV AND EATING ON
ON TV TRAYS I'M THOSE HOUSES ARE
IN DIRE NEED OF. OF UPGRADE AND.
PAINTING AND I YARD WORK AND
FRANKLY GIVING THEM AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MOVE INTO A
SMALLER HOME AND TAKE THAT
PORTABILITY ALONG WITH THEM
WOULD BE A REALLY IMPORTANT TO
THEM. NOT ONLY THAT BUT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS DESPERATELY NEED.
AT TAX RESOURCES AND WHAT THIS
DOES IS THIS HOME WOULD BE SOLD
WHICH IS.
WHICH WOULD THEN PROVIDE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR.
PROPERTY TAXES TO COME TO THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT. ENTITIES IN IN
THAT IN A NEW STREAM THAT WOULD.
HELP THEM TO HELP THEM
TREMENDOUSLY.
SO BY ALLOWING SOME RELIEF TO
SEE AT THIS THE EMPTY THE
SENIORS AND THE AB EMPTY NESTERS
CAN KEEP THEIR PROPERTY TAX AT
THE SAME RATE WHICH IS A ALLOWS
THEM TO DOWNSIZE. WITHOUT THE
RESULT IN TAX INCREASE AND SO
THE SALE OF ANY HOUSE GETS
REASSESSED
FOR PROPERTY TAX PURPOSES AT IT
CURRENT SALE PRICE THIS BRINGS A
NEW. INCREASED TAX DOLLARS FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENT WHICH IS ALWAYS
A GOOD THING. WE NEED TO MAKE
MAKE HOUSING MORE AFFORDABLE AND
AVAILABLE. AND MAKE SURE THAT
DOLLARS FOB FLOW BACK INTO THE
ECONOMY AND STABILITY FOR
STATEMENTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU WITNESS IN SPORT.
AS FOR CARLISLE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS I WAS
GONNA GIVE YOU ONE FACTOID.
ALMOST THREE QUARTERS OF ALL
HOMEOWNERS FIFTY FIVE AND OLDER
HAVE NOT MOVED SINCE THE YEAR
TWO THOUSAND.
THAT'S A HUGE
APPLY OF HOUSING THAT WE CAN TAP
IN WITH THIS LEGISLATION.
I'M GONNA JUST.
LEAVE IT AT THAT AND I WILL
HAVE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE.
BUT OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WHEN THIS OPPOSITION MENACES IN
OPPOSITION.
WATCH OUT.
NOT THE FIRST PERSON THIS
COMMITTEE THAT'S WHEN IT HIT ME
WITH THE DOOR TODAY.
ZERO THE GOVERNMENT THE
CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM
ASSOCIATION ON BEHALF OF OUR
MEMBERS AT INCLUDING A CS CNC TO
YEAH ALSO LISTED IN THE ANALYSIS
HERE WERE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
MEASURE. ON ANY TIME THAT WE'VE
CONSIDERED IN A MIXED PENSION TO
PROP SYSTEM SIXTIES BEEN VERY
VERY CAREFULLY TAILORED. ON THIS
MEASURE UNFORTUNATELY IS
EXTRAORDINARILY EXPANSIVE ON
ESSENTIALLY ALLOWING ANYONE
ANYWHERE.
TO EXPAND UPON THE BENEFITS
AVAILABLE.
UNDER PROP SIXTY WITH A
REDUCTION OF UP TO ONE POINT
THREE BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
OUGHT TO THE STATE. AND FOR
THOSE REASONS WE OPPOSE THANK
YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
ANTHONY TOWN HALL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION WITH PORTFOLIO TO
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF. CALIFORNIA.
.
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
MATH MACAULAY. A WE TWO WERE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE.
HAVE BEING THE* THE. THE
LOCAL AGENCIES THAT PROVIDE THE
BULK OF THE.
ESSENTIAL SERVICES TO THE
COMMUNITY. WHEN SOMEONE MOVES
INTO THAT COMMUNITY.
WE FEAR THAT THIS MEASURE WILL
IN FACT JEOPARDIZES.
VERY SERVICES THAT THEY'RE
EXPECTING TO GET WHEN THEY.
RELOCATED. I APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME THANK YOU.
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
I THINK I WOULD LIKE CLOSE MADAM
CHAIRMAN OUT ALLOW MISTER
CARLYLE TO RESPOND.
I JUST WANNA RESPOND WITH REGARD
TO THE PROJECTED REVENUE LOSS NO
THE OTHER REALTORS OF SUBMITTED
ALMOST A MILLION SIGNATURES. OF
FOR INITIATIVE THAT LARGELY
MIRRORS THIS AND WE RECENTLY MET
WITH. OF THE ALEJO AND MANY
THINGS WERE REVEALED IN THAT
MEETING. UP THEY DON'T DO A
DYNAMIC ANALYSIS SO.
INCREASES IN CAP GAINS TAXES.
INCOME TAX SALES TAX DOT MATRIX
OR TEXT NONE OF THAT'S INCLUDED.
THEY ADMIT THAT THERE'S BE A
INCREASE IN THE DEMAND FOR
HOUSING BUT THERE CAN
CALCULATIONS DO NOT. A ALLOW FOR
ANY MORE HOUSING PRODUCTION
SO WE THINK THAT WE'VE WE'VE
TAKEN QUITE A BIT OF EXCEPTION
TO THEIR.
REVENUE ESTIMATES.
I THINK AND AT WHAT THE REASON
THEY KEEP TALKING TO THE CONSOLE
IS BECAUSE THE ARAB LAST YEAR WE
DID. ONE TIME FIFTY FIVE IF
YOU'RE AN OLDER.
THAT WAS DONE BACK IN
CONSTITUTION AMENDMENT THAT SO
YOU JUST YOU KEPT REFERRING TO
SENIORS AND SO I JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE I UNDERSTAND. WHERE WE
CORRECTLY? RIGHT NOW AT THIS
BILL SHOWS A FISCAL LOSS OF
ESTIMATES POPPING OF ONE POINT
THREE BILLION DOLLARS TO WE HAVE
AN. IDEA WHERE WE POWER
REPLACING THOSE WHO THAT WAS
MISTER CARLYLE'S COMMENTS WAS
THAT AND THEY'RE IN THEIR
ANALYSIS IT IS MISSING A LOT OF
ELEMENTS SO WHERE DO YOU THINK
THERE ANNOUNCES FALLS MISTER
CARLO. AS I SAID THEY DON'T
INCLUDE INCREASE AYE AIR THAT
FOOTAGE HAVE YOU DONE AN
ANALYSIS OF WHAT THE LOSS WOULD
BE. IN YOUR PURVIEW.
BOB NO WE'VE NOT ESTIMATED THAT
IF I COULD ADDRESS AT THAT WHEN
WE LOOKED OUT.
PROPOSITION SIXTY AND THEN I
MOVED INTO PROPOSITION NINETY
I'M THERE'S ELEVEN COUNTIES THAT
ARE CURRENTLY OUT OF FIFTY
COUNTIES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA PARTICIPATING
PROPOSITION. I'M NINETY AND A
LOT OF THOSE COUNTIES BUTTRESS
EACH OTHER AND SO YOU KNOW YOU
COULD ABOUT EACH OTHER AND SO
WHEN THEY WERE LOOKING AT SOME
THE OTHER COUNTIES THEY WERE
LOOKING AT FORGET EXACTLY WHICH
ON A POLITICAL NAY NOW SAYS.
THAT THEY'RE LOOKING AT LESS
THAN TWO TENTHS OF A PERCENT
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN WHAT THE
PROPERTY TAXES WERE BEFORE THE
JOINT PROP THAT PROP NINETY AND
THEN AFTER JOINING PROP NINETY.
THAT THEIR ARGUMENT ORIGINALLY
WAS THAT THEY WERE ESTIMATING
THAT PEOPLE WOULD WANT TO MOVE
TO DESTINATION CITIES AND LIVING
IN SIN MEDINA COUNTY THEY WOULD
SAY OKAY A. LOT OF PEOPLE WOULD
WANT TO MOVE TO MAYBE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY OUT TO PALM SPRINGS ARE
MOVED TO ORANGE COUNTY INTO THE
BEACH AREAS AND YOU WOULD HAVE
CITIES THAT YOU WOULD HAVE
PROPERTY TAXES MOVED INTO THOSE
COMMUNITIES. THEY DO NOT FIND
THAT TO BE TRUE OR ACCURATE SO I
I DON'T ANTICIPATE THAT WE'RE
GONNA SEE THAT ON WHOLESALE
LEVEL ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHEN THIS IS EXPANDED.
AND I DO REMEMBER HAVING THAT
CONVERSATION WITH THAT WOULD TO
A CLOSE OPEN RESPECTFULLY ASK DR
THOUGH WHEN YOU HAVE A QUORUM.
THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH.
LIVING FILE ITEM SEVEN AB TWENTY
FOUR FIFTY NINE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN WOULD YOU LIKE TO OPEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS.
AS YOU KNOW ALL TOO WELL ONE OF
THE BIGGEST BARRIERS FOR
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES SEEKING
TO OBTAIN AND MAINTAIN HEALTH
CARE COVERAGE IS AFFORDABILITY.
THROUGH COVER CALIFORNIA WE HAVE
TAX CREDITS IN PLACE TO HELP
COVER THE COST OF PREMIUMS. FOR
THOSE MAKING LESS THAN FOUR
HUNDRED PERCENT OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LIMIT OR IF. I FELT THAT
FPL. HOWEVER FOR INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES WHOSE INCOME EXCEEDS
FOUR HUNDRED PERCENT OF THE FPL
THERE ON THEIR OWN.
KEEP IN MIND FOR TO PERCENT OF
THE FPL IS FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR AN INDIVIDUAL.
AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY NINE
CREATES A REFUNDABLE TAX CREDIT
FOR THOSE OVER THE FOUR HUNDRED
PERCENT FPL TO HELP COVER THE
COST OF THEIR PREMIUM. THIS
CREDIT IS EQUAL TO THE COST OF
HEALTH INSURANCE PREMIUMS TO THE
LOWEST COST BRONZE PLAN FOR THE
INDIVIDUAL THAT EXCEEDS EIGHT
PERCENT OF THEIR MODIFIED
ADJUSTED GROSS INCOME.
ESSENTIALLY THIS BILL ENSURES
THAT NO CALIFORNIAN SPENDS MORE
THAN A PERCENT OF THEIR INCOME
ON HEALTH INSURANCE PREMIUMS.
TOO MANY OF OUR CONSTITUENTS ARE
FACING THE IMPOSSIBLE CHOICE OF
PAIN FOR HOUSING TRANSPORTATION
GROCERIES UTILITIES. OR BUYING
HEALTH INSURANCE
THE RESEARCH IT'S CLEAR
IMPROVING AFFORDABILITY WILL
INCREASE ENROLLMENT AND MOVE US
CLOSER TO UNIVERSAL COVERAGE.
AS YOUR ANALYSIS OUTLINES I'M
HAPPY TO AMEND THE BILL TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE CONCERNS
RAISED BY THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD. ON PAGE FIVE OF THE
ANALYSIS.
YOU'LL FIND.
TECHNICAL IN CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS THAT WE'VE WORKED OUT
WITH THE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
STAFF I LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR HELP.
AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FOUR FIFTY
NINE IS A BROAD COALITION OF
SUPPORT AND THERE IS NO
OPPOSITION AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE.
BEST PAL ON BEHALF HEALTHAXIS
CALIFORNIA WERE PLEASED TO BE
HERE IS THE SPONSORS OF THIS
MEASURE. AS MISS FRIEDMAN SAID
FOR CALIFORNIANS WHO MAKE MORE
THAN FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS IS
AN INDIVIDUAL OR SIXTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS AS A MARRIED
COUPLE.
THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT IS NOT
PROVIDE ANY ADDITIONAL SUBSIDIES.
IN.
YOUR DISTRICT MADAM CHAIR I
HAPPENED TO LOOK THIS MORNING A
COUPLE OF VERY COUPLE WHOSE AGE
SIXTY TWO WOULDN'T PAY BETWEEN
FOURTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS AND
NINETEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS. FOR
COVERAGE THAT HAD A SIX THOUSAND
THREE HUNDRED DOLLAR DEDUCTIBLE
FOR EACH OF THEM.
I THINK MOST OF US COULD
REMEMBER WHAT IT WAS LIKE TO TRY
AND LIVE ON SEVENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS WHEN WE'RE STARTING OUT.
THAT'S A LOT OF MONEY TO SPEND
AND PREMIUMS. IN THE BAY AREA
THE PREMIUMS WOULD BE EVEN
HIGHER CLOSER TO TWENTY THREE
OVER TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS.
THAT'S WHY IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
WE GIVE FOLKS HELP PAYING FOR
THEIR.
HEALTH INSURANCE SO THAT THEY
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE
MORE AFFORDABLE HEALTH INSURANCE
THIS WOULD BUILD ON AN EXTEND
THE HELP THAT THE AFFORDABLE
CARE ACT HAS GIVEN PEOPLE. TO
THOSE PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT COVERED
BY THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT AND
FOR THAT REASON WE'RE HAPPY TO
SPONSOR THE SPECIAL.
I MARK HURLBERT WITH SMALL
BUSINESS MAJORITY WE ARE A AND
NATIONAL CALIFORNIA BASED SMALL
BUSINESS EDUCATION AND ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION AND WE BELIEVE
WATCH MENORES AND SMALL
EMPLOYERS ARE CENTRAL TO HEALTHY
LOCAL THRIVING COMMUNITIES. AND
THEREFORE WE'VE HOSTED HUNDREDS
OF WORKSHOPS HERE IN CALIFORNIA
HELPING UNDERSERVED
ENTREPRENEURS AND SMALL
EMPLOYERS UNDERSTAND HOW THE ACA
ACTUALLY CAN SUPPORT THEIR SMALL
BUSINESS. OVER THE PAST SIX
YEARS ACA HAS PROVIDED HEALTH
CARE TO MILLIONS OF INDIVIDUALS
MANY OF THOSE NEWLY INSURED WORK
FOR SMALL EMPLOYERS OR OUR
ACTUALLY SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
OR SOME.
OR ENTREPRENEURS THEMSELVES
THEY SHE HAS BEEN ESSENTIAL FOR
CALIFORNIA SELF EMPLOYED FOLKS
ROUGHLY THREE HUNDRED SEVENTY
THOUSAND SELF EMPLOYED
CALIFORNIANS RECEIVE THEIR
INSURANCE THROUGH THE INDIVIDUAL
MARKETPLACE.
AND ADDITIONALLY ACCORDING TO
THE U. S. SMALL BUSINESS
ADMINISTRATION THE MEDIAN INCOME
IN CALIFORNIA FOR SELF EMPLOYED
INDIVIDUALS IS AROUND FIFTY SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
IT PUTS THEM JUST ABOVE THE CUT
OFF FOR RECEIVING PREMIUM
ASSISTANCE THROUGH A COVER
CALIFORNIA OF THIS BILL WOULD
HELP THOSE SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
WHO MAYBE JUST OVER THE
THRESHOLD. A BE ABLE TO AFFORD
INSURANCE INCREASING
AFFORDABILITY FOR EMPLOYEES WHO
PURCHASE THEIR INSURANCE THROUGH
THE INDIVIDUAL MARKETPLACE WILL
ALSO MAKE SMALL BUSINESSES MORE
COMPETITIVE AS THEY'RE SEEKING
AT A HIGHER TALENT. ROUGHLY HALF
CALIFORNIA'S PRIVATE SECTOR
EMPLOYEES WORK FOR SMALL
BUSINESS AND SMALL BUSINESSES
HAVE CREATED ROUGHLY TWO THIRDS
OF ALL THE NEW JOBS SINCE THE
RECESSIONS. AND THE BUSINESSES
HERE CALIFORNIA CREATING MOST
THOSE JOBS HAVE BETWEEN ONE AND
FIVE EMPLOYEES AND IS THE SMALL
FIRMS THEY'RE MOST LIKELY TO BE
UNABLE TO AFFORD TO OFFER
EMPLOYER SPONSORED INSURANCE.
AND WE KNOW THE REMAINING
UNINSURED ROUGHLY FORTY FOUR
PERCENT ACTUALLY WORK FOR A
COMPANY WITH LESS THAN FIFTY
EMPLOYEES. AND AND A RECENT
SURVEY FOUND THAT AFFORDABILITY
IS THE DRIVING ISSUE AND SO
THEREFORE BY EXPANDING
AFFORDABILITY IN THE MARKETPLACE.
WE CAN ENSURE THE MORE WORKERS
OF THE SMALLEST FIRMS CAN ALSO
AFFORD COVERAGE THIS BILL WILL
HELP MAKE INSURANCE MORE
AFFORDABLE BOTH THE SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS AND THEIR
EMPLOYEES AND WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST I.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER IN SUPPORT.
YOU.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING THAT WOULD LIKE BECAUSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE WE HAVE A QUORUM OH NO WAIT
FIRST I HAVE TO GO THROUGH THE
AMENDMENTS AND. WE HAVE THE
FORCES APPLIED A GREAT
INDIVIDUALS MAKING MORE THAN
FOUR HUNDRED PERCENT OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LINE DEFINE THE
TERMS OTHER PUBLIC PROGRAM
STANDARDIZED BENEFIT DESIGN. AND
DEPENDENT.
I REQUIRE COVER CALIFORNIA TO
CERTIFY THE CREDIT CLARIFY THE
CREDIT APPLIES TO THE CALENDAR
YEAR.
AND CLARIFY THAT THE CREDIT MAY
BE USED FOR PLANS OTHER MEN A
BRONZE PLAN AND YOU'VE AGREED TO
ALL THOSE AMENDMENTS GOT
SLIGHTLY ALRIGHT GREAT.
THEIR RECOMMENDATIONS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
WHEN WE HAVE A QUORUM THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU OFFER
.
WEAVING TO FILE ITEM THREE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG WOULD YOU
LIKE TO OPEN ITS AB NINETEEN
TWENTY TWO.
BUT THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS. I AM PLEASE RESENT AB
NINETEEN TWENTY TWO THE
CALIFORNIA COMPETITIVENESS AND
INNOVATION ACT A BILL TO PROVIDE
COMPREHENSIVE TAX RELIEF FOR
MIDDLE CLASS FAMILIES AND SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE STRUGGLING UNDER
CALIFORNIA'S BURDENSOME TAX
STRUCTURE.
I JUST LAST WEEK THE GOVERNOR
RELEASE THE MAY REVISION OF ITS
PROPOSED STATE BUDGET AND
ANNOUNCE THE SURPLUS OVER OF
OVER NINE BILLION DOLLARS FOR
THIS YEAR ALONE. AND A NEW
RECORD BUDGET AND NEARLY TWO
HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS
WELL THE SURPLUS IS BEING
CELEBRATED BY SACRAMENTO. THE
REALITY REMAINS THAT HARD
WORKING FAMILIES CONTINUE TO
STRUGGLE WITH HOUSING COSTS ARE
SPIRALING OUT OF CONTROL WE HAVE
HOMELESSNESS THAT IS RAVAGING
OUR COMMUNITIES AND TRAFFIC
CONGESTION THAT HAS GOTTEN WORSE.
CALIFORNIANS CONTINUE TO PAY THE
HIGH STATE PERSONAL INCOME TAX
THE HIGHEST SALES TAX THE SECOND
HIGHEST GAS EXPLANATION AND THE
NATION'S ONLY FRANCHISE TAX ON
SMALL BUSINESSES.
IS BECOMING MORE MORE DIFFICULT
FOR CALIFORNIANS WHO LIVE AND
WORK IN OUR STATE.
WELL CALIFORNIA NOW RANKS AS THE
FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD YOU MUST PUT THAT INTO
CONTEXT.
OUR CON ME CONTINUES TO FAVOR
CERTAIN GEOGRAPHIC AREAS OF THE
STATE WHILE OVERLOOKING
COMMUNITIES SUCH AS THE ONES I
REPRESENT.
THE RESIDENTS OF MY DISTRICT
NEED AND DESERVE.
REAL TAX RELIEF.
THE BUDGET SURPLUS TO BE PUT TO
BETTER USE BY RETURNING AT LEAST
A PORTION OF IT TO TAXPAYERS SO
THAT THEY CAN PUT IT BACK INTO
THE ECONOMY.
THE SURPLUS CAN BE USED TO HELP
HOMEOWNERS OR THOSE LOOKING TO
BUY THEIR FIRST HOMES BY
INCREASING THE HOMEOWNERS
PROPERTY TAX EXEMPTION WHICH HAS
REMAINED UNCHANGED SINCE
NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO. EVEN AS
HOUSING COSTS HAVE SKYROCKETED.
WELL WE CAN USE THE SURPLUS
PROVIDE RELIEF FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES BY REPEALING THE
ANNUAL FRANCHISE TAX.
THIS TAX EFFECTIVELY PENALIZES
CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES FOR
WANTING TO PROVIDE JOBS AND
SERVICES IN THE COMMUNITIES WE
SERVE.
THE CALIFORNIA COMPARED THIS AND
INNOVATION ACT WILL BRING THESE
IMPORT REFORMS SO THAT
CALIFORNIA CAN REMAIN
COMPETITIVE WITH OTHER STATES.
ESPECIALLY FOR CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES AND SMALL BUSINESSES
THAT ARE STRUGGLING TO SURVIVE.
WE MUST REMEMBER THAT THIS IS
NOT SACRAMENTO'S MONEY IT IT
BELONGS IN THE HANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO EARNED IT. WITH
ME TO TESTIFY SUPPORT IS DAVID
WOLF OF THE HOWARD JARVIS
TAXPAYERS.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS GOOD
AFTERNOON DAVID WILL FOOT THE
HOWARD JARVIS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. MEMBERS THERE JUST THAT
HANDFUL OF THINGS IN THE BILL
THAT I WANT TO FOCUS ON HERE MY
TESTIMONY IN THE FIRST ONE IS
THE HOMEOWNERS EXAM.
MEMBERS THE HOMEOWNERS EXEMPTION
HAS BEEN INCREASED SINCE
NINETEEN SEVENTY.
CALIFORNIA IS FOURTEEN THINK
COMBINED STATE AND LOCAL
PROPERTY TAXES EVEN AFTER PROP
THIRTEEN AND A LOT OF THAT HAS
TO DO WITH THE CONTINUED
INCREASE INVOLVED LOCAL BONDS
AND PERSONAL TAXES.
AN INCREASE IN THE HOMEOWNERS
EXEMPTION WHICH RIGHT NOW IS
JUST SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS.
WOULD GO ON WAY TO MAKE HUNDRED
SHIP. MORE AFFORDABLE FOR PEOPLE
AND TO THE EXTENT THAT.
AN INCREASE IN EXEMPTION MAKES
OWNERSHIP HOMEOWNERSHIP MORE
AFFORDABLE GOVERNMENT
COMPLAINING PARTNER ROLE IN
INCREASING HOME CAPACITY.
NUMBER TWO AN INCREASE IN THE
RENTER'S CREDIT IS SOMETHING WE
NEED HERE IN CALIFORNIA FOR THE
SAME REASON ONE THIRD OF
CALIFORNIA RUNNER SPEND HALF
THEIR TAKE HOME PAY RIGHT NOW.
ON RENT ONE THIRD.
IT'S LITTLE WONDER THEN THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS A TWENTY PERCENT
POVERTY RATE NUMBER ONE IN THE
NATION AND IT'S ALSO LITTLE
WONDER THAT TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE LEFT THE SAN FRANCISCO
BAY AREA. JUST LAST YEAR MAINLY
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T AFFORD
HOUSING.
NUMBER THREE IS INCOME TAX
RELIEF CALIFORNIA HAS BY FAR THE
HIGHEST INCOME TAX IN THE NATION
AND IT'S THE MOST PROGRESSIVE
TAX IN THE NATION ALSO WITH NINE
SEPARATE BRACKETS.
RETURNING MONEY INTO THE POCKETS
OF MIDDLE CLASS FAMILIES IS
IMPERATIVE.
MISTER FUNG MENTION THAT WE DO
HAVE A SIX BILLION DOLLAR
SURPLUS AND I THINK THAT EXACTLY
HITS ON THIS POINT.
WITH HOUSING ENERGY AND CONSUMER
GOODS CONTINUING TO INCREASE WE
DO NEED MORE DOLLARS PUT INTO
THE POCKETS OF MIDDLE CLASS
TAXPAYERS. AND THIS BILL WOULD
DO THAT SO ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THE WITNESS IS A SPORT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
SHAUN LOUIS THE NATIONAL
FEDERATION OF INDEPENDENT
BUSINESS REPRESENTING OVER
TWENTY THOUSAND SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS. IN SUPPORT OF AB
NINETEEN TWENTY TWO IS IT WOULD
PROVIDE IMMEDIATE AND DIRECT
FINANCIAL RELIEF TO THOUSANDS OF
STRUGGLING SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
AND WORKING FAMILIES IN THE
STATE. IT'S BEEN SAID BEFORE BUT
IT'S WORTH REPEATING THAT SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE THE ENGINE OF THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY BUT NINETY
NINE POINT EIGHT PERCENT OF ALL
BUSINESSES BEING SMALL
BUSINESSES. HALF OF ALL
EMPLOYEES ARE EMPLOYED BY SMALL
BUSINESSES AND HALF OF OUR GDP
IS GENERATED BY SMALL BUSINESSES.
BUT WE ALSO KNOW IS THAT THE
SMALL BUSINESS CLIMATE IN
CALIFORNIA. HAS ROOM FOR
IMPROVEMENT AND THAT CAN BE DONE
STARTING WITH THIS BILL EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN TWENTY TWO WITH SMART.
TARGETED TAX REFORM
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT SIXTY PERCENT
OF OUR MEMBERS IN THIS IS COMMON
FOR MANY SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
IN GENERAL.
FILE A SOLE PROPRIETORS OF THE
REDUCTION IN THE INDIVIDUAL TAX
RATES WOULD BE DIRECTLY
BENEFICIAL TO THE SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS THAT FILE ASIL
PROPRIETORS. SECONDLY THE
MINIATURE FRANCHISE TAX IS A
PUNITIVE TAX TO SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS AND ESPECIALLY BURDENSOME
TO THE SMALLEST EMPLOYERS. ARE
WHO HAVE TO PAY THAT EVERY YEAR
SO WE THINK THAT TAX POLICY
SHOULD BE A REFLECTION OF OUR
PRIORITIES IN THE STATE. IF WE
CAN AFFORD TAX BREAKS AND TAX
CREDITS FOR BIG MOTION PICTURE
BIG SOLAR WE THINK WE CAN
PROVIDE TAX RELIEF TO THE ENGINE
OF OUR ECONOMY SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS AND WE ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
REX DOT BEHIND WITH CALIFORNIA'S
PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
NGUYEN. WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NINE COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE.
SEEN I WOULD LIKE BECAUSE I WAS
A VAST RIVA.
BUT I WANT TO SAY REALLY BRIEFLY
I I UNDERSTAND THE BASIC GOALS
OF WHAT YOU'RE PROPOSING HERE.
AND READING TODAY IS THAT THE
GOVERNOR IS LOOKING TO DO A TAX
OVERHAUL OF EVEN THOUGH HE'S
LEAVING. US. IS IRONIC HOWEVER
THERE ARE THOSE ON THIS
COMMITTEE WHO HAVE THOUGHT ABOUT
WHAT THAT WOULD LOOK LIKE AND
WHAT WE WILL DO MOVING FORWARD
AND SO THAT CONVERSATION I
BELIEVE WILL. WILL HAPPEN AT
SOME POINT IN OUR TENURE HERE
AND I'LL HOPEFULLY THIS THIS WE
GIVEN NO RECOMMENDATION TO BUT
HOWEVER HOPEFULLY YOU WILL
DECIDE TO BE PART OF THAT
CONVERSATION WE HAVE IT.
ABSOLUTELY.
WE HAVE A QUORUM WILL LOOK
THINKING.
LIVING TO FILE ITEM SIX MISTER
GARCIA WOULD YOU LIKE TO PRESENT
AB TWENTY THREE TWELVE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIRMAN
COLLEAGUES.
AB TWENTY THREE TWELVE MODIFIES
THE CALIFORNIA COMPETES TAX
CREDIT PROGRAM SO THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS.
RESERVE A PORTION OF THE ON
UNALLOCATED. AND RECAPTURED THAT
TAX CREDIT FROM PRIOR YEAR IN.
THEIR BIDDING PACKAGE FOR NEW OR
EXPANDING BUSINESSES.
AS A TWO POINT FOUR TRILLION
DOLLAR ECONOMY CALIFORNIA
REMAINS IN ATTRACT SPOT FOR
BUSINESS.
HOWEVER WHILE OTHER STATES HAVE
RECENTLY PROVIDED INCENTIVES FOR
BUSINESSES STARTING INVESTMENTS.
IN THE RESPECTIVE STATES
CALIFORNIA. CLEANERS TO LAG
BEHIND.
BUSINESSES THAT ARE REGIONALLY
SIGNIFICANT WOULD BE ABLE TO
BENEFIT FROM MAYBE TWENTY THREE
TWELVE IF THEY GO. IF THEY MEET
CERTAIN HIRING INVESTMENT TARGET
SET FORTH.
IN THE WRITING WITH GOMEZ. HE
BETWEEN THREE TWELVE WILL INDUCE.
INDECISIVE BUSINESSES WHO WISH
TO MOVE INTO OUR STATE BY GIVING
THEM MORE CERTAINTY REGARDING
ECONOMIC RESOURCES AND
INCENTIVES BY PROVIDING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS.
THE TOOLS.
TO PROPERLY INCENTIVIZE
BUSINESSES THIS WILL NEED THEM
TO REMAIN ECONOMICALLY
COMPETITIVE.
AS WELL AS ATTRACT AND RETAIN
JOBS IN OUR STATE. THANK YOU AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR RIVAL.
WITH THIS IN SUPPORT.
BUT I'M CHAIR MEMBERS OFFERED.
MEDINA HE ON BEHALF OF THEY
IMPERIAL IRRIGATION DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT AND WE APOLOGIZE FOR NOT
GETTING OUR LETTER INTO.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NINE COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING THEM MISTER DARCY WOULD
LIKE BOTH THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ATTENTION AFFECT THAT'S RIGHT WE
ACQUIRE WILL HAPPILY VOTE TO
HAVE THE RECOMMENDATION TO
PASSED APPROPRIATIONS.
LIVING TO FILE ITEM TEN AB
TWENTY NINE THIRTY SIX MISTER
NAZARIAN WOULD YOU LIKE TO OPEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS YOU'VE ALREADY
HAD A PARADE OF INDIVIDUAL SPEAK
ON THIS ISSUE. A AND A
PRESENTATIONS ALL BEING VERY
BRIEF. A THIS IS A THIS IS A TAX
CREDIT BILL THAT.
IMPACTS ALL OF THE STATE AND
BENEFITS ALL OF THE STATE. AND
IT ALSO HAS A DIRECT IMPACT
IMPACT ON NOT JUST FINANCIAL.
BENEFITS BUT ALSO.
FAMILY RELATED BENEFITS
DISPROPORTIONATELY ANSWER
POCKETS OF THE STATE. ADDING
MISS CHAIR YOU AND I BOTH. A CAN
RELATE TO THAT WITH OUR
CONSTITUENTS WHO.
I HAVE HAD TO SPEND QUITE A BIT
OF TIME AWAY FROM FAMILIES AND.
AS A SIDE EFFECT OF OF KEEPING
THESE JOBS IN THE STATE. AND
GENERATING REVENUE IN THE STATE
A IT'S ALSO HAD THE BENEFIT OF
KEEPING FAMILIES HOPE. SO I'LL
JUST LEAVE IT WITH THAT
PERSPECTIVE AND.
UP WITH ME IS MELISSA PATEK.
THANK YOU ON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MELISSA ATTACK
WITH THE MOTION PICTURE
ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF.
OUR ASSEMBLY MEMBER NEWS ARIENS
BILL TO EXTEND THE PRODUCTION
TAX CREDIT FOR FIVE ADDITIONAL
YEARS THE CURRENT PROGRAM IS
BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL ONE HUNDRED
THIRTY PROJECTS LOCATING IN
CALIFORNIA. EMPLOYING OVER THE
FIRST.
THREE YEARS OF THE PROGRAM OVER
TWENTY TWO THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS
AND BELOW THE LINE JOBS.
BOB GOOD MIDDLE CLASS JOBS I
UNION JOBS WITH ON HEALTH
INSURANCE PENSION BENEFITS.
OUGHT THE AGGREGATE SPENDING.
AS ESTIMATED BY THE CALIFORNIA
FILM COMMISSION ON THESE
PROJECTS HAS BEEN FIVE POINT
NINE BILLION DOLLARS
CONTRIBUTING TO CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
POINTS OUT REALLY ALL THROUGHOUT
THE STATE SO. ON BEHALF OF OUR
MEMBER COMPANIES WE ARE
ENTHUSIASTICALLY IN SUPPORT OF
AN EXTENSION OF THIS PROGRAM FOR
FIVE ADDITIONAL YEARS. THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WHEN IT'S OAKLAND.
THANK YOU
I GREG HAYES HERE ON BEHALF OF
ONE BROTHERS ENTERTAINMENT IN
SUPPORT.
HELLO PAT CHOICE ON BEHALF OF
NBCUNIVERSAL IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
GRAMLEY WITH CBS CORPORATION AND
SHOWTIME NETWORKS RUN WITH WORK.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
BECAUSE OF QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
MISTER JERRY WOULD YOU LIKE
CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY HUMBLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. ONLY A QUORUM THEIR
RECOMMENDATIONS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS THANK YOU.
SEEING NO OTHER AUTHORS THE
CHAIRS GOING TO PERCENT HER BILL
ITEM FOR AB TWENTY TWO SEVENTEEN
MADAM CHAIR WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY.
THINK YOU I'M. VICE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TODAY I'M HERE TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY TWO SEVENTEEN
WHICH ENACTS THE BIDDY MASON
GOLDEN STATE CREDIT.
CREDIT PROGRAM TO PROMOTE CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT AS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
CALIFORNIANS TO MITIGATE THE
IMPACT OF THE NEW FEDERAL TAX
LAW.
BRIDGET BIDDY MASON WAS BORN A
SLAVE WHO WON HER FREEDOM SHE
WENT ON TO SUCCESSFULLY SERVE AS
A PROMINENT MIDWIFE AND NURSE
ASSISTING AND HUNDREDS OF BIRTHS.
TO MOTHERS ON EVERY WALK OF LIFE.
BE MASON ALSO ESTABLISHED THE
FIRST AMERICAN METHODIST
EPISCOPAL CHURCH IN EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY TWO. THE FAME CHURCH IS
ONE OF THE MOST PROMINENT MY
COMMUNITY WITH EIGHTEEN THOUSAND
MEMBERS TO CONTRIBUTE OVER TWO
MILLION ANNUALLY TO SUPPORT MORE
THAN FORTY.
PROGRAM COMMUNITY PROGRAMS AB
TWENTY TWO SEVENTEEN ESTABLISHES
THE BODY MASON PROGRAM IN HONOR
OF PETTY'S WORK TO SUPPORT THE
COMMUNITY AND OUR COMMITMENT TO
FELT PHILANTHROPIC THE LAST
THIRTY.
ULTIMATELY THE NEW FEDERAL TAX
LAW WILL CAP THE STATE. AND
LOCAL TAX DEDUCTION AND RAISE
THE STANDARD DEDUCTION RESULTING
IN AN INCREASE OF THE AFTER TAX
PRICE OF GOVERNMENT PROVIDING
GOODS AND SERVICES.
SCORE A CORRESPONDING INCREASE
IN FEDERAL HOLD TIGHT FEDERAL
DEFICIT WILL PRESSURE CONGRESS
TODAY THAT'S FEDERAL FUNDS FROM
GOVERNMENT PROGRAMS SETTLING
CALIFORNIA AND OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WITH GREATER COSTS
WHILE UNDERMINING THEIR ABILITY
TO RAISE REVENUES.
AB TWENTY TWO SEVENTEEN CREATES
A CONTRIBUTED SYSTEM WHICH
BRINGS A THREE FOLD BENEFIT TO
SCHOOLS AND NONPROFITS THE STATE
IN CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS ALLOWING.
ALLOWS DONATING TAXPAYERS TO
CHOOSE WHICH NONPROFIT AND
SCHOOLS ARE DONATIONS WILL GO
TOWARDS PROMOTING CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT ENCOURAGING THE
CONTINUED SUPPORT OF NON PROFITS.
I HAVE WITH ME TODAY PRESS
PROFESSOR DANIEL HAVE ALL FROM
THE UNIVERSITY OF CHICAGO AND
PRESIDENT DATE DARIEN SANSKI
FROM UC DAVIS TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
I AM DANIEL HOW MOMENT ASSISTANT
PROFESSOR AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CHICAGO LAW SCHOOL. OF FOR MORE
THAN A CENTURY CONGRESS IN A
REFLECTION OF FEDERALISM VALUES
DEEPLY ROOTED IN THE AMERICAN
POLITICAL TRADITION HAS ALLOWED
TAXPAYERS TO DEDUCT FROM THEIR
FEDERAL FEDERAL TAXES WHAT THEY
PAY IN STATE AND LOCAL INCOME
AND PROPERTY TAXES.
IN DECEMBER TWENTY SEVENTEEN A
NARROW MAJORITY OF CONGRESS
BROUGHT THAT TO IN AND IMPOSE A
TEN THOUSAND DOLLAR CAP ON THE
STATE AND LOCAL TAX DEDUCTION.
AT THE SAME TIME CONGRESS
ELIMINATED PERSONAL EXEMPTIONS
AND DEDUCTIONS FOR DEPENDENTS
AND REPLACE THEM WITH A LARGER
STANDARD DEDUCTION WHICH HAD THE
EFFECT OF REDUCING THE NUMBER AFTER TAX PRICE OF
SATAN UP SERVICES AND RAISES THE
AFTER TAX PRICE OF CHARITABLE
CONTRIBUTIONS?
IN THE SHORT TERM WE EXPECT
CHARITABLE CONTRIBUTIONS TO
DECLINE THE NATIONAL COUNCIL OF
NONPROFITS EXPECTS CHARITABLE
GIVING TO GO DOWN BY AT LEAST
THIRTEEN BILLION DOLLARS NEXT
YEAR. AS A RESULT OF THIS
FEDERAL TAX CHANGE
IN THE LONG TERM WE THINK IT
WILL BE HARDER FOR STATES AND
LOCALITIES TO RAISE REVENUE
THROUGH TAXES.
WHO LOSES FROM THEIR SWELLED
STUDENTS FROM THE PRE QUE TO PHD
LEVEL AT BECAUSE EDUCATION IS
THE NUMBER ONE SPENDING ITEM FOR
STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN
THE NUMBER ONE DESTINATION OF
CHARITABLE GIFTS?
PATIENTS IN PUBLIC AND NONPROFIT
HOSPITALS WHICH RELY ON STATE
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT REVENUES
AND CHARITABLE CONTRIBUTIONS.
AND FAMILIES THAT ARE RELIANT
UPON SOCIAL SERVICES PROVIDED BY
STATES AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
BY NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS.
WHAT TO DO ABOUT IT? THE BIDDY
MASON GOLDEN STATE CREDIT
PROGRAM IS AN INNOVATIVE WAY TO
ENCOURAGE CALIFORNIANS TO
SUPPORT STATE AND LOCAL
INSTITUTIONS AND NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS AT THE SAME TIME.
AND IT BUILDS OFF THE FACT THAT
CHARITABLE CONTRIBUTIONS REMAIN
FULLY DEDUCTIBLE FOR HOUSEHOLDS
THAT CONTINUE TO ITEMIZE BUT
THAT RUN UP AGAINST THE TEN
THOUSAND DOLLAR SALT CAP.
IT ALSO TAKES ADVANTAGE OF THE
FACT THAT THE IRS IS TAKING THE
POSITION BUT A CHARITABLE
CONTRIBUTION IS DEDUCTIBLE AS A
CHARITABLE CONTRIBUTION NOT
WITHSTANDING THE FACT THAT A
DONOR RECEIVES A STATE TAX
CREDIT.
SO HOW DOES IT WORK A IMAGINE A
FAMILY IN THE TWENTY FOUR
PERCENT BRACKET.
IT MAKES A HUNDRED DOLLAR
CONTRIBUTION TO A QUALIFIED
ENTITIES SUCH AS A PUBLIC
UNIVERSITY OR A KEY TO TWELVE
SCHOOL OR A PUBLIC CHARITY LIKE
THE UNITED WAY.
THE QUALIFY CHARITY WILL SAY THE
UNITED WAY GIVES THE FAMILY A
GOLDEN STATE CREDIT WORTH EIGHTY
DOLLARS.
THE FAMILY IS ACTUALLY FOUR
DOLLARS BETTER OFF AT THE END OF
THE DAY BECAUSE IT GETS AN
EIGHTY DOLLAR STATE TAX CREDIT
AND A TWENTY FOUR DOLLAR FEDERAL
DEDUCTION SO IT'S GIVING UP A
HUNDRED DOLLARS AND GETTING A
HUNDRED AND FOUR DOLLARS BACK IN.
TAX BENEFITS.
THE UNITED WAY TRANSFERS NINETY
DOLLARS TO THE STATE IN EXCHANGE
FOR THE CREDIT BUT IT STILL TEN
DOLLARS BETTER OFF BECAUSE IT
GETS A HUNDRED DOLLARS FROM THE
FAMILY.
AND THE STATE IS TEN DOLLARS
BETTER OFF BECAUSE IT GOT NINETY
DOLLARS FROM UNITED WAY AND GAVE
A TAX CREDIT OF EIGHTY DOLLARS.
SO THAT'S THE ATTRACTION OF THE
BIDDING MASON GOLDEN STATE
CREDIT PROGRAM AT THE NEW
FEDERAL TAX LAW MAKES IT HARDER
FOR CALIFORNIA TO RAISE REVENUE
BUT THE BIDDING MASON GOLDEN
STATE CREDIT PROGRAM GIVES THE
STATE IN NEW REVENUE SOURCE.
THE NEW FEDERAL TAX LAW MAKES IT
HARDER FOR NONPROFITS TO ATTRACT
CHARTABLE CONTRIBUTIONS BUT
THIS PROGRAM HELPS THEM OUT. AND
THE NEW FEDERAL TAX LAW DEALS A
BLOW TO CALIFORNIA FAMILIES THAT
RELIED ON THE SALT DEDUCTION BUT
THE PD STATE GOLDEN STATE AT THE
BIDDING MASON GOLDEN STATE
CREDIT PROGRAM PROVIDES THOSE
FAMILIES WITH RELIEF.
LASTLY I JUST WANTED TO TAKE THE
CHAIRWOMAN FOR PUTTING THIS
PROPOSAL FORWARD I THINK IT CAN
AND WILL BE A MODEL FOR HER THE
OTHER STATES.
IN ADDITION WOODS
SUPPORT.
AND OF.
I'LL JUST BOMB BRIEFLY I'M
ADDRESS SOME OF THE FEDERAL TAX
LAW ISSUES INVOLVING THIS
PROGRAM SO.
HOW ONE STOP EMPHASIZING THAT
THIS LAWS GROUNDED IN THE SAME
TAX LAW PRINCIPLES THAT
UNDERSCORE THE HUNDRED PROGRAMS
AND THIRTY OTHER STATES THAT PRE
EXISTED? DID CHANGES MADE IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AND IN
PARTICULAR THE PRINCIPLE AS
DANIEL'S SAID IS THAT.
FEDERAL TAX LAW DOES NOT LOOK AT
HOW THE STATE. DOES NOT EVALUATE.
A CHARITABLE CONTRIBUTION AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL BASED ON WHAT
HAPPENS AT THE STATE LEVEL
THAT'S ALWAYS BEEN THE PRINCIPAL
AND THAT IS HOW I ON THE OTHER
PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN EVALUATED.
AND IT IS ALSO THE PRINCIPLE
WHICH UNDERSCORES S. B. TWO TWO
SEVEN. FROM THE SENATE AS WELL
AS BILLS HAVE BEEN PASSED IN NEW
YORK AND NEW JERSEY.
I'LL ALREADY SO THE QUESTION IS.
BOB. HOW SHOULD WE THINK ABOUT
THIS BILL IN WHICH A IN RELATION
TO THOSE PRINCIPLES AND RELATED
TO THOSE OTHER BILLS?
I IMPORTANT THING TO NOTE IS
THAT.
THIS IS THAT ALL OF THESE BILLS
ARE GROUNDED IN THE SAME
PRINCIPLES AND THEY SHOULD ALL
BE SUPPORTED ON THE HOW ARE THEY
SHOULD ALL ON.
NOT BE CHALLENGED.
BY THE IRS ON THE OTHER HAND
IT'S NOT IT IS NOT IMPOSSIBLE ON
THAT THEY MIGHT BE ON IN
PARTICULAR COMMENTATORS HAVE
SUGGESTED THAT THERE COULD BE A
DISTINCTION MADE BETWEEN. THE
PRE EXISTING PROGRAMS AND THESE
NEW PROGRAMS BASED ON WHICH
ENTITIES RECEIVE BENEFIT AND IN
PARTICULAR WHETHER OR NOT THE
ENTITY IS A GOVERNMENT OR SOME
OTHER KIND OF NONPROFIT ENTITY
OR AT LEAST NOT THE SAME AT.
GOVERNMENT ENTITY. ACTUALLY
GIVING OUT THE TAX CREDIT.
NOW. ONE EMPHASIZE THAT THAT
DISTINCTION ITSELF WOULD BE AD
HOC AND NOT GROUNDED IN IN THE
LAW WOULD ULTIMATELY. FELL I
BELIEVE NEVERTHELESS IT IS.
A PROPOSAL THAT IS OUT THERE AND
ONE OF THE.
REALLY APPEALING FEATURES OF AB
TWO TWO ONE SEVEN IS THAT IT
SIMULTANEOUSLY DOES SOMETHING
EXTREMELY DESIRABLE FROM A
POLICY PERSPECTIVE. NAMELY
BROADEN THE TAX BENEFIT TO A
LARGER SWATH OF CIVIL SOCIETY.
AND AT THE SAME TIME AS IT'S
DOING SOMETHING THAT MAKES A LOT
OF SENSE BEEN UPON POLICY
GROUNDS. IT WILL ALSO BE MORE
ROBUST RELATIVE TO ONE
PARTICULAR KIND OF CHALLENGE.
THAT IS POSSIBLE ON THAT THE IRS
MIGHT HARM LEVY AGAINST THESE
OTHER KINDS OF PROGRAMS PASSED
BY OTHER STATE.
THE COURTS QUORUM.
IF I DIDN'T INTERRUPT YOU RIGHT
NOW WE HAVE TO HAVE A QUORUM.
HAVE LOVED IT SECRETARY
FICTIONAL ROLE.
BURKE THEIR.
ROBERT.
BONTA.
CHU GRAY CHIU.
GRAY.
MCCARTY MELENDEZ MULLIN. QUIRK
HERE.
VOEPEL YOUR.
HAVE A QUORUM.
IT WILL PROCEED ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MORNING MISTER CHAIR ARE GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS JENNIFER FEARING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF NONPROFITS AND
OUR TEN THOUSAND ORGANIZATION
POLICY ALLIANCE.
WERE SUPPORTIVE WE WE ALONG
WITH ALL ON PROFITS.
IN THE UNITED STATES WERE
DEEPLY CONCERNED AND REMAIN
DEEPLY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
IMPACT THAT THE FEDERAL TAX.
REFORM EFFORT IS GOING TO HAVE.
SPECIFICALLY FOR CHARITIES BUT
THE IMPACT.
ON DEDUCTIONS AND SO WE SEE.
THE CREATIVITY OF THIS BILL AND
THE CONSISTENCY OF IT WITH OTHER.
RELATED EFFORTS IN OTHER STATES
THAT HAVE BEEN IN A BAND IN
EXISTENCE FOR SOMETIME AS HAVING
THE POTENTIAL TO EASE. BURDENS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE NEW.
FEDERAL TAX CHANGES FOR SOME
PICS SOME CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS
AND AND EXPANDING THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SUPPORT NON
PROFITS AND EDUCATIONAL PROGRAM
SO WE WOULD URGE OUR AYE VOTE
PLEASE.
ADDITIONAL WHAT MRS IN SUPPORT
SEEING NINE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SHE NON BRING IT TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MUST COURT.
NEVER MOTION AND A SECOND.
SO MY MY CONCERN HERE IS THAT IT
CAN BE ANY CHARITY. AND WATER
MOTT ONE OF MY CONCERNS WOULD BE
THAT.
.
JUST THAT JUST THE LOSS IN
STADIUM COM.
WHICH I.
THERE IS SOME LOSS IN STATE
INCOME I BELIEVE FROM THIS.
IS THAT TRUE OR NOT TRUE.
I BELIEVE THAT AS I IN IN ITS
MOST RECENT ITERATION THERE'S NO
LOSS IN STATE INCOME OR
PROJECTED IT ALSO WILL NO LONGER
BE ANY. CHARITY IT NEEDS TO BE A
PUBLIC CHARITY RATHER THAN A
PRIVATE FOUNDATION IN ORDER TO
QUALIFY FOR QUALIFIES A
QUALIFIED ENTITY OKAY THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SEEING NOT.
IS BERKELEY LIKE CLOSE FOLLOW UP
MR BONTA QUICK QUESTION COMMENT
I THINK IF YOU LEADERS ABOUT
THIS THAT I LIKE THAT THE
CHANGES FROM. ANOTHER VEHICLE
THAT'S EVER ALREADY MOVING IN%
OUR LEGISLATURE AND.
WHEN ASKED IF I COULD BE
COAUTHOR THE NEXT TIME YEAH IF
YOU'RE TAKING A.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER BONTA.
NO EMOTION MISTER QUIRK SECOND
AYE MR BONTA.
MADAM CHAIR THERE IS LIKELY A
QUESTION ABOUT.
SO CALL THE ROLL PLEASE BURKE
AYE BURKE AYE BROUGH. BROWN NOT
VOTING BONTA. BONTA AYE CHIU.
CHIU AYE GRAY.
MCCARTY MELINDA ES.
MULLIN.
QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE VOEPEL.
THE PILOT BUT SOME CALL IT NEEDS
TO.
MATTER CHERRY BILLS ARE CALLED
NEEDS TO VOTES.
NEXT UP FILE ITEM EIGHT MR BLUM
AB TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY FOUR
.
THANK YOU MR VICE CHAIR MADAM
CHAIR.
.
I'LL BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR.
THE ASSISTANCE YOU'VE PROVIDED
THE SOFTWARE PUBLISHING INDUSTRY
CONTRIBUTED NEARLY THIRTY TWO
BILLION DOLLARS TO CALIFORNIA'S
GROSS DOMESTIC. PRODUCT IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN CALIFORNIA IS
HOME TO OVER NINE HUNDRED VIDEO
GAME COMPANIES WITH OVER THIRTY
THREE THOUSAND EMPLOYEES.
IN THE UNITED STATES COMPETITION
IN THIS ARENA IS GROWING AND THE
COMPETITION HAS BECOME FIERCE.
NOW ALL FIFTY STATES HAVE A
SHARE OF THE INDUSTRY TWENTY ONE
OF THOSE STATES ARE CURRENTLY
OFFERING FINANCIAL INCENTIVES
AND SEVERAL SEVERAL OF THE UP
AND COMING STATES. HAVE
INCREASINGLY LARGE FOOTPRINTS
CALIFORNIA'S STILL LEADS WITH
TWENTY SEVEN PERCENT OF THE
NATION'S INDUSTRY. BUT ACCORDING
TO THE MILKEN INSTITUTE THE GAP
BETWEEN CALIFORNIA AND OTHER
STATES IS CLOSING.
CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO SERVE AS
THE HEADQUARTERS OF SEVERAL OF
THE LARGEST VIDEO GAME
PUBLISHERS NOT ONLY IN THE
UNITED STATES BUT THE WORLD
HOWEVER. LIKE IT'S COUNTERPART
HOLLYWOOD THE COMPARATIVE
ADVANTAGE OF HAVING A LEAD IN
VIDEO GAME EMPLOYMENT. AND
CORPORATE HEADQUARTERS MAY NOT
BE ENOUGH TO MAINTAIN
CALIFORNIA'S CONSISTENT GROWTH
IN THE INDUSTRY.
OR REMAIN A LEADER IN FOSTERING
THE SMALL DEVELOPMENTAL STEW
DEVELOPMENT STUDIOS THAT ARE SO
ESSENTIAL TO CALIFORNIA'S EDGE
IN BOTH. VIDEO GAME PRODUCTION
AND EMPLOYMENT.
FURTHERMORE WHILE AVERAGE
SOFTWARE INDUSTRY WAGES IN
CALIFORNIA ARE STRONG.
I IN FACT FIFTY THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS GREATER THAN THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE.
AND SECOND ONLY TO WASHINGTON
THE GAMING DEVELOPMENT HUBS OF
LOS ANGELES IN THE BAY AREA HAVE
SOME OF THE HIGHEST COST OF
LIVING IN THE COUNTRY.
PRINCIPALLY DUE TO A HOUSING
COSTS.
CAUSING POTENTIAL EMPLOYEES TO
FLEE TO STATES THAT ARE MORE
AFFORDABLE.
TELL PRESERVE THE CALIFORNIA
VIDEO GAME INDUSTRY AB TWENTY
FIVE SEVENTY FOUR WILL CREATE
THE CALIFORNIA VIDEO GAME.
PRODUCTION PRESERVATION ACT.
BY ESTABLISHING A NEW TAX
EXPENDITURE PROGRAM IN THE FORM
OF A SALES AND USE TAX EXEMPTION.
FOR THE VIDEO GAME INDUSTRY.
SPECIFICALLY THE EXEMPTION WOULD
APPLY TO TANGIBLE PERSONAL
PROPERTY PURCHASED
BUY A QUALIFIED PERSON.
FOR USE PRIMARILY IN THE
RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT OR
DESIGN OF DIGITAL INTERACTIVE
MEDIA.
ANOTHER WORDS VIDEO GAMES.
MANY STATES OFFER VARIOUS FORMS
OF FULL OR PARTIAL SALES TAX
EXEMPTION THAT OUR INDUSTRY
SPECIFIC. AND AB TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTY FOUR WILL HELP FUTURE
PROOF IF YOU WILL CALIFORNIA'S
VIDEO GAME INDUSTRY. HELPING TO
KEEP THE INDUSTRY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA BY GETTING IN FRONT
OF THE PROBLEM. AND PROVIDING
THE INDUSTRY WITH INCENTIVES
KEEP THE VIDEO GAME INDUSTRY
BASED RIGHT HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU I ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
AND WITH ME TODAY IS TOM FOLKS
FROM THE ENTERTAINMENT SOFTWARE
ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OTHER
MEMBERS OF MANY THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF BLOOM.
ARMENIANS TOM FOLKS IN THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF STATE AFFAIRS FOR
THE ENTERTAINMENT SOFTWARE
ASSOCIATION.
WHERE THE TRUE TO SIT TRADE
ASSOCIATION THAT REPRESENTS THE
COMPUTER VIDEO GAMEINDUSTRY
HERE IN THE UNITED STATES?
A BEHALF OF OUR MEMBERSHIP.
I WANNA THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITIES HAVE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTY FOUR AND THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLOOM FOR HIS SPONSORSHIP.
OF THIS LEGISLATION AS OUR
SUMMER BLOOM MENTIONS SEEKS TO
ESTABLISH PARTIAL SALE PARTIAL
SALES AND USE TAX
EXEMPTION FOR SPECIFIED PROPERTY.
WE BELIEVE THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
FIRST STEP I ENSURING THE
INDUSTRY'S LONG TERM VIABILITY
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
AS OUTLINED TO.
BY THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
.
THE COMPUTER VIDEO GAME
INDUSTRIES INCLUDE INCREDIBLY
VALUABLE ON. TO THE NATIONAL
ECONOMY PARTICULARLY CALIFORNIA
THE DOMESTIC VIDEO GAME INDUSTRY
GENERATED THIRTY SIX BILLION
DOLLARS IN REVENUE AND TWENTY
SIXTEEN. AND WELL OVER A HUNDRED
MILLION INTERNATIONALLY WE
EXPECT THIS NUMBER TWO INCREASES
THE INDUSTRY CONTINUES TO GROW.
MUCH LIKE WE HEARD EARLIER TODAY.
MUCH LIKE THE OF THE FILM AND
TELEVISION AYE INDUSTRIES VIDEO
GAMES ARE SYNONYMOUS WITH THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
IN PEWTER VIDEO GAME DEVELOPMENT
IS THE QUINTESSENTIAL CALIFORNIA
INDUSTRY COMBINING. THE
ENTERTAINMENT CAPITAL POLY WOOD
WITH THE HIGH TECH CAPITAL OF
SILICON VALLEY.
AND.
IT IS THE MILKEN INSTITUTE
DECLARED FEBRUARY THIS YEAR THE
ES A AND THE ESSAY HAS BEEN
SHARING ANECDOTALLY FOR LAST
SEVERAL YEARS CALIFORNIA IS
INDEED. FACING A GROWING
DOMESTIC AND INTERNATIONAL
COMPETITION FOR ITS THRIVING
VIDEO GAME INDUSTRY.
IT'S OUR HOPE THAT THE
INCREMENTAL SO INCREMENTAL STEPS
TAKEN BY THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
SHORT TERM.
CAN HELP TO ENSURE CALIFORNIA
RIM RETAINS ITS TOP RANKING AS
THE NUMBER ONE STATE FOR VIDEO
GAME DEVELOPMENT.
IN TERMS OF COMPANIES AND JOBS
BY ACTING NOW THE LEGISLATION
PROPOSED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BLOOM WILL ASSIST IN HANSON
CALIFORNIA'S COMPETITIVE EDGE IN
THIS IMPORTANT AREA. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND ATTENTIONTO
THIS IMPORTANT MATTER AND I'D BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
ON THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS MAY
HAVE.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING THAT WOULD YOU LIKE CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
WE HAVE A WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND AND I HAVE VIDEO I HAVE
THE VIDEO GAME INDUSTRY IN MY
DISTRICT AS WELL AND IT'S AND IS.
IT IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT WE
APPRECIATE THAT YOU COME TO
CALIFORNIA BUT THAT YOU STAY
HERE IS IMPORTANT TO US AS WELL
SO. WITH THAT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO PASS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS THE FILING TO
CALL THE ROLL. BURKE AYE BURKE
AYE BROUGH. BRO I AM BONTA.
BONTA AYE CHIU.
CHIU AYE GRAY.
MCCARTY.
MELINDA THIS MULLIN.
MULLIN I.
QUIRK NO WORK NO VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
THANK YOU.
WE HAVE TO REMAINING BILLS OF
BOTH AUTHORED BY THE CHAIR.
FILE ITEM NINE AB TWENTY SEVEN
HUNDRED.
FILE ITEM THIRTEEN AB THIRTY ONE
NINETY SEVEN.
THAT OF SHARE WHICHEVER ONE YOU
LIKE TO RESENT ON FIRST MULTI
TWENTY SEVEN HUNDRED FIRST.
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AB TWENTY SEVEN HUNDRED
CREATES AN INCENTIVE FOR
BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA TO
PARTNER WITH EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTES IN DEVELOPING AND
PROMOTING A SKILLED WORKFORCE.
AB TWENTY SEVEN HUNDRED CREATES
A THIRTY AND FIFTEEN PERCENT TAX
CREDIT ON QUALIFY EXPENDITURES
BY BUSINESSES THAT PARTNER WITH
COMMUNITY COLLEGES OR CSU'S.
THE FIRST CREDIT IS GEARED
TOWARDS EMPLOYERS WHO HAVE THE
CAPACITY IN THE KNOWLEDGE TO
DESIGN A TRAINING PROGRAM IT
EITHER COMMUNICATIVE OR CSU THAT
BEST MEETS THEIR NEEDS
BENEFITING THOSE EMPLOYERS. THAT
TEND TO HAVE GREATER RESOURCES
AND CAN AFFORD TO DEVELOP A
PROGRAM FROM THE GROUND UP.
THE SECOND CREDIT IS DESIGNED TO
ENCOURAGE EMPLOYERS TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE DOING WHAT
MATTERS PROGRAM WHICH IS
CURRENTLY SET UP.
AND.
THANKS.
TO ENCOURAGE GREATER
COLLABORATION AMONG QUEEN
COLLEGES AND EMPLOYERS
BENEFICIAL TO EMPLOYERS THAT
HAVE A NEED TO UNDERSTAND THE
MARKET BUT LACK THE KNOWLEDGE
AND RESOURCES NECESSARY TO
DEVELOP A CURRICULUM. INITIALLY
AGREED TO TAKE THE AMENDMENTS
LISTED IN THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS.
IF TRENDS CONTINUE BY TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE CALIFORNIA IS LIKELY
TO FACE A SHORTAGE OF ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION SKILLED WORKERS.
ACCORDING TO A REPORT OF THE
TASK FORCE ON WORKFORCE JOB
CREATION AND A STRONG ECONOMY
FAR TOO MANY CALIFORNIANS DO NOT
POSSESS THE RIGHT SKILLS. AND
EDUCATION TO OBTAIN THESE JOBS
EMPLOYERS IN KEY INDUSTRIES HAVE
DIFFICULT FINE. EMPLOYERS IN THE
CUTEST KEY INDUSTRIES ARE HAVING
DIFFICULT FINDING THOSE TO FIND
THOSE TO FILL THOSE JOB OPENINGS.
LESS CALIFORNIA IMMEDIATELY
BEGINS TO ADDRESS THIS MISMATCH
THE STATE'S ECONOMIC PROSPERITY
IN THE SUCCESS AND INCOME
MOBILITY OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS ARE THREATENED.
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY CUTS AND
I WILL.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
BUT IT MEMBERS HOMONYMS KISH
RAJIN AND.
AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT THE
BILL I HAVE.
WORKED AT THE INTERSECTION OF
TECHNOLOGY ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS. MOST RECENTLY
SERVING IN GOVERNOR BROWN'S
ADMINISTRATION AS HEAD OF GOBIZ
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF BUSINESS
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT.
AND I WOULD SIMPLY SAY THAT OF
THE EXPERIENCES THAT I'VE HAD
OVER THOSE YEARS WATCHING THE
DRAMATIC EVOLUTION OF OUR
ECONOMY IN THE CORRESPONDING
LABOR MARKET. I IT EXPOSES AYE
AYE IN URGENT NEED
TO ENCOURAGE AND TO BRING MORE
BUSINESS AND INDUSTRY TO THE
TABLE AND TO COLLABORATE WITH
OUR MAJOR WORKFORCE AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT SYSTEMS. TO TRY TO
REBUILD LADDERS OF OPPORTUNITY
AND PROSPERITY FOR PEOPLE ALL
ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
AND THE NEED IS DRAMATICAND THE
OPPORTUNITY IS NOW AND I THINK
LEGISLATION LIKE AB TWENTY SEVEN
HUNDRED.
ARE VERY IMPORTANT SENDING A
SIGNAL AND CREATING THE RIGHT
INCENTIVES FOR BUSINESS AND
INDUSTRY TO PARTICIPATE
COLLABORATIVE LEE IN A
SUBSTANTIVE WAY TO HELP US
RESHAPE AND MODERNIZE OUR WORK
FOR SYSTEMS TO CREATE THE KIND
OF OPPORTUNITY IN CALIFORNIA
THAT WE NEED TO. HERE TO EXPRESS
THEIR SUPPORT APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY
THANK YOU DISH AWARENESS ISN'T
SUPPORT.
SE NON WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
WISHING TO SPEAK ON THE OTHER.
SEEING NONE.
RANCHO LOOKED CLOSE UP AT
CALIFORNIA RECENTLY BECAME THE
FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD AND YET WE STILL HAVE OVER
ONE POINT FIVE MILLION JOBS
COMING IN TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
FIVE THAT WE HAVE NOT PREPARED
OUR. OUR CONSTITUENTS FOR. FUN
FOR THAT REASON I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST RIGHT.
THANK YOU AND NOW LET ME
REITERATE THE AMENDMENT YOU
AGREED TO ONE APPLY THE TAX
CREDITS TO TAX WILL YEARS
BEGINNING ON OR AFTER JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY NINETEEN M. OF THE
SUNSET DATE. AND REPEAL DATE FOR
BY ONE YEAR TO DISALLOW BOTH
THIS CREDIT AND A BUSINESSES
OPTION FOR THE SAME ITEM OF
EXPENSE. THREE TRACTOR TOTAL
NUMBER OF TRAINING PROGRAMS
CREATED WITH THIS TAX CUT ALONG
WITH THE NUMBER OF ENROLLEES AND
THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS THAT
OBTAIN. EMPLOYMENT RELATED TO
THIS TRAINING. THOSE MOTION BY
MISTER VOEPEL SECOND AYE MR CHIU
MADAM CLERK WHICH KALRA MOTIONS
TO PASS IS A MINUTE TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE AYE BURKE
AYE BROUGH. ROLE AYE BONTA.
BONTA I CHU. CHU AYE GRAY.
MCCARTY MELENDEZ MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE QUIRK NO WORK NO
VOEPEL.
THE BILL MIGHT.
JOE THINKS IF
ZERO I HAVE A HOSPITAL OR FILE
OF FINAL ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN AB
THIRTY ONE NINETY SEVEN THANK
YOU THAT MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
TODAY I'M HERE TO PRESENT EIGHT
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY ONE NINETY
SEVEN THE CALIFORNIA AEROSPACE
JOBS ACT. THIS CONTINUES IN
EXISTING TAX EXEMPTION FOR
PERSONAL PROPERTY RELATED TO
SPACE FLIGHT THAT HAS PROVEN TO
BE SUCCESSFUL SINCE IT WAS
SIGNED INTO LAW MOVE THE BILL IN
RECENT YEARS CALIFORNIA
AEROSPACE INDUSTRY HAS
TRANSFORMED DRAMATICALLY FROM AN
ENTIRELY GOVERNMENT RUN INDUSTRY
TO A MULTITUDE OF PRIVATE FIRMS
ALL CONTRIBUTING. TO THE
HUMANITIES NEXT EXPEDITION INTO
THE STARS. IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA ALONE THE PRIVATE
AEROSPACE INDUSTRY SUPPORTS
NINETY TH OVER NINETY THOUSAND
JOBS. A NUMBER THAT RIGHT A
NUMBER THAT RISES IN EXCESS OF A
HUNDRED THOUSAND WHEN ACCOUNTING
FOR SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES AT THE JET PROPULSION
LABORATORY AND AN OUTSIDE. THESE
JOBS ARE WELL PAYING MIDDLE
CLASS JOBS WITH AVERAGE WAGES OF
OVER A HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS.
NEARLY DOUBLED THE AVERAGE WAGE
OF OTHER INDUSTRIES
EXTENDING THIS THE PERSONAL
PROPERTY TAX EXEMPTION FOR
EQUIPMENT USED IN SPACE BY
PROVIDE CERTAIN NEED TO A
RAPIDLY INVOLVING INDUSTRY
WANDERING CALIFORNIA SPACE
INNOVATORS EXPAND IMPROPER IN
THIS STATE. WITH.
I HAVE TWO WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT AND WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST.
THANK YOU WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING ARE GONNA GET
EVENING ARE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MATT ON I'M
THE SENIOR DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FOR SPACEX.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TESTIFY TODAY SPECIFICALLY
I'M HERE. ON BEHALF OF SPACEX IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE ONE NINE
SEVEN AND WE WOULD LIKE TO THANK
CHAIRMAN BURKE.
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE. AB THREE ONE NINE SEVEN
SIX TWO ONE EXTEND EXISTING
STATE STATUTE.
RELATED TO THE CLASSIFICATION OF
QUALIFIED PROPERTY USED IN SPACE
FLIGHT IS INVENTORY.
NOT SUBJECT TO PERSONAL PROPERTY
TAX
THIS TAX PROVISION WAS PASSED
INTO LAW SEVERAL YEARS AGO WITH
OVERWHELMING BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND IT HAS PAID OFF IN TERMS OF
STIMULATING THE CAP THE GROWTH.
OF CALIFORNIA'S COMMERCIAL SPACE
INDUSTRY IT IS SUPER IMPORTANT
TO MAINTAIN A CONSISTENT FAIR
AND REASONABLE TAX.
CODE FOR THIS INDUSTRY.
WE ARE IN A DYNAMIC AND EXCITING
TIME FOR THE COMMERCIAL SPACE
INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA IS
LEADING THE WAY. FROM THE
BEGINNING SPACEX'S LEVERAGED
AMERICAN AND MORE SPECIFICALLY.
CALIFORNIAN INNOVATION AND
TECHNOLOGY TO CREATE THE MOST
ADVANCED SPACE LAUNCH VEHICLES.
IN SPACECRAFT IN HISTORY. THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS DEEPLY
ARE WOVEN IN OUR STORY.
AND IS CONTINUES TO BE THE
LOCATION OF THE OVERWHELMING
MAJORITY OF OUR MORE THAN SIX
THOUSAND EMPLOYEES.
SPACEX'S GROWN MARKEDLY SINCE
TWO THOUSAND TO WHERE WE STARTED
WITH JUST THREE EMPLOYEES IN A
GARAGE IN EL SEGUNDO.
AD TODAY WE ARE PROUD TO
PROVIDE A DEPENDABLE AND
AFFORDABLE RIGHT TO SPACE. FOR
NASA THE DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE
INTERNATIONAL CUSTOMERS AND THE
WORLD'S MOST SOPHISTICATED
COMMERCIAL SATELLITE OPERATORS.
COMMERCIALLY SPACEX'S RESTORED
THE UNITED STATES IS THE LEADER
IN GLOBAL COMMERCIAL SATELLITE
LAUNCH.
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN DECADES
AS RECENTLY AS TWENTY TEN U. S.
MARKET SHARE.
IN THIS.
MARKETS BASIC COLLAPSED ZERO
PERCENT.
BUT LAST YEAR'S SPACEX
CONDUCTED MORE THAN SIXTY
PERCENT OF THE WORLD'S
COMMERCIAL LAUNCHES. AND WE WILL
DO EVEN MORE AT THIS YEAR. WITH
SPACE SIX NOW THE LEADER IN
COMMERCIAL SATELLITE LAUNCH
WORLDWIDE WE ARE BROUGHT. JOBS
AND ECONOMIC ACTIVITY BACK TO
THE U. S. AND SPECIFICALLY BACK
TO CALIFORNIA.
I. AS I MENTIONED WE MAINTAINED
OUR.
MANUFACTURING AND DESIGN.
FACILITY IN HAWTHORNE
CALIFORNIA BUT WE ALSO MAINTAIN
A NETWORK OF SUPPLIERS TO ENSURE
THAT WE HAVE ACCESS TO THE
HIGHEST QUALITY. MATERIALS AND
PARTS WITH OVER THIRTEEN HUNDRED
SUPPLIERS IN CALIFORNIA ALONE.
IN SINCE TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN
WE SPENT MORE THAN TWO BILLION
DOLLARS.
WITH THESE COMPANIES.
WE ALSO LAUNCH OUR ROCKETS IN
PART FROM VANDENBERG AIRFORCE
BASE WHERE WE HAVE A LAUNCH AND
LANDING COMPLEX.
AT LANDING.
COMPLEX FOR HER LAUNCH COMPLEX
FOR.
AND WE HAVE A RECENTLY EXPANDED
OUR FOOTPRINT AT THE PORT OF LOS
ANGELES FOR OUR DRAGON IN FALCON
NINE. RECOVERY EFFORTS AS WELL
AS THE NEXT GENERATION ROCKET
WERE BUILDING.
OVERALL SB SIX CALIFORNIA
FACILITIES IMPACT OVER TWENTY
THOUSAND JOBS.
AND OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS
BASICS PRODUCTION LAUNCH AND
ADMINISTRATIVE FACILITIES IN
CALIFORNIA. HAVE EXCEEDED SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS IN ECONOMIC
IMPACT.
SO THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO APPEAR.
IN FOR YOUR WORK ON AB THIRTY
ONE NINETY SEVEN WE ENCOURAGE
THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TO
SUPPORT THE MEASURE THANK YOU
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU IT MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WE THANK.
MEDICARE FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD WE THINK THERE'S A
FEELING USE OF.
TAX CODE IN ORDER TO
INCENTIVIZE THIS ACTIVITY IT'S
HOME GROWN I'M ANDREW ANSWERING
I'M HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
PORT OF LOS ANGELES.
NOW WE OWN AND OPERATE THE PORT.
TIED LAST PROPERTY UNDER THE
STATE PIPELINES ACT WE THINK
THIS IS A FITTING USE AND IT'S
WHAT WAS ENVISIONED WHEN THE.
STATE THAILAND'S ACT WAS ENACTED
IN WITH THAT WE SUPPORT THANK
YOU DITION WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THANKS TO THE COMMITTEE DRAW
COOK FOR THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS IN TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
I CAN TRY CHEN AGAIN LOOKING AT
THINGS FROM A CALIFORNIA
ECONOMIC PERSPECTIVE ESPECIALLY
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IS A
CRITICAL INDUSTRY PAYS WELL
GREAT JOBS ARE GREAT GROWTH
OPPORTUNITY I MEAN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU DISH
AWARENESS ISN'T SUPPORT SEEING
NONE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
NOW MOVING CHAIRS.
YEAH.
SEEING NONE BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE MISTER QUIRK.
YEAH SO. I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL UP MY CONCERN IS WELL FIRST
OF ALL I GENERALLY DON'T SUPPORT
BILLS LIKE THIS HOWEVER. IT IS
CLEAR THAT YOU'RE NOT AT A
THRESHOLD WHERE YOU CAN MAKE
FUNDING YET.
AND THEREFORE IT'S NOT ALL CLEAR
YOU'D BE IN CALIFORNIA IF YOU
HAVE TO PAY A LARGE FEE SO I
THINK THIS IS NOT REWARDING
THINGS WOULD HAPPEN ALREADY.
WHICH IS MY CONCERN WITH MOST
TAX BREAKS THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT I THINK.
DOES BECAUSE YOU TO.
LOOK TWICE IN CALIFORNIA NONE
THE LESS YOU DO HAVE A SOUTH
TEXAS LOST SIGHT.
LAUNCH SITE NEAR BROWN'S VEIL.
AND I'M JUST.
YOU KNOW CONCERNED ABOUT HOW
MUCH OF THE BUSINESS WILL BE
KEEPING HERE IN CALIFORNIA IN
THE LONG RUN.
SURE OUR COMMITMENT CALIFORNIA
IS.
SUBSTANTIAL AND AND LONG TERM
THE MAJORITY OVERWHELMING
MAJORITY OF THE JOBS THAT ARE
THE EMPLOYMENT ITS BASICS HAVE
HAS IS IN CALIFORNIA.
THE BROWN TO LAUNCH SITE IS
ACTUALLY A GEOGRAPHICALLY
LOCATED TO SUPPORT CERTAIN
ORBITS THAT WE CANNOT LAUNCH
FROM CALIFORNIA BECAUSE THEY'RE
GOING IN EAST TO WEST COAST
TRAJECTORY.
A CORRECT WE NEED TO BE SOUTH
AND WE NEED TO LAUNCH OVER WATER
WHEN WE'RE OF LAUNCHING THAT
TRAJECTORY WHEN WE LAUNCHED INTO
POLAR ORBITS NORTH AND SOUTH.
THAT IS WHEN WE LAUNCHED FROM
VANDENBERG. SO.
IT IS REALLY A MATTER OF
PHYSICS.
IN PART WHY WE'RE THERE.
THANK YOU OTHER MEMBERS WISHING
TO SPEAK ON THIS ITEM.
SEEING NO.
THERE'S A MOTION BY MISTER QUIRK
SECOND BY MISTER CHIU MADAM
CHAIR DON'T CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AND I.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
LUSHNESS DE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE AYE AYE
BURKE AYE BROUGH.
BROUGH AYE BONTA. BONTA AYE CHIU.
CHIU AYE GRAY.
GRAY AYE MCCARTY.
MELINDA SMOLAN.
MULLIN AYE QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE
VOEPEL. VOEPEL AYE.
EIGHT ZERO SHOUT EIGHT ZERO.
OKAY HOLDEN.
OKAY RICHARD LIVING OF RETURNING
A FILE ITEM ONE A. B. SEVENTEEN
THIRTY FOUR MOVED TO BELL.
MOTION AND SECOND.
A SECOND.
SO.
THANK YOU.
MS SILENTLY COLOR.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE AYE AYE
BURKE AYE BURL. GROW AYE BONTA.
IT SEVENTEEN THIRTY FOURTH ITEM
ONE IT'S.
CALLED RUN.
BONTA AYE CHIU.
SHALL I GRAY.
GRAY AYE MCCARTY.
MULLIN THIS MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE QUIRK AYE QUIRK I'VE
CHO. VOEPEL OUT THAT BILL IS
EIGHT ZERO LIVING AT THAT BOTH
OUT EIGHT ZERO LIVING A FILE
ITEM TO AB SEVENTEEN FORTY EIGHT.
AND MOTION AND A SECOND.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
WITH SO MANY COLORS.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE NO BURKE NO
BROUGH.
BRO I BONTA.
BONTA NOT VOTING CHIU.
CHIU NOT VOTING GRAY.
GRAY NO MCCARTY.
CORDY ARE AYE MELINDA'S.
BUT MULLIN.
MULLIN NOT VOTING. NO.
QUIRK NO.
VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I.
ITEM NUMBER TWO.
WITH ON MCCARTY.
I TO.
NO.
OKAY.
THAT ITEM FAILS TWO TO THREE.
WHAT?
ONE THREE TWO TO THREE.
LETTING THE FILE ITEM FOR.
AB TWENTY TWO SEVENTEEN.
BUT WE DON'T TWO THREE WHICH IS
TO.
IF I DON'T MAKE I LIVE IN A FILE
ITEM THREE AB NINETEEN TWENTY
TWO.
FONG.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
IS HIGHLY CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE NO WORK NO
GROW. GROW AYE BONTA.
BONTA NO CHIU.
JUNO GRAY.
GRAY NO MCCARTY.
CARTY NO MELINDA'S MULLIN.
MULLIN NOT VOTING QUIRK NO QUIRK
NO VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I.
THAT MOTION THAT FAILS TO TO SIX.
LIVING A FILE ITEM FOR AB TWENTY
TWO SEVEN MOVE THE BELL WHICH IS
A SONG CALLED WE'RE CALLING THE
ABSENTEES.
ON THAT
GRAY.
GRAY AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I.
MELINDA THIS MULLIN.
MULLIN I.
THAT GOES OUT SEVEN ZERO.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM FIVE EASY
TWENTY TWO FIFTY NINE AND A
MOTION AND A SECOND.
GIVEN MOTION AND A SECOND.
MISS HOLLY COLE OR OF. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE AYE BURKE
I'VE PEARL. BRO I'VE BONTA.
BONTA RHS YOU.
CHIU AYE GRAY.
GRAY AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MULLIN THIS MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE QUIRK NOT VOTING WORK
NOT VOTING VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I.
THAT BILLS OUT EIGHT ZERO.
MOVING A FILE ITEM SIX AB TWENTY
THREE TWELVE.
I NEED A MOTION AND A SECOND.
I HAVE A MOTION.
AS I GET.
DONALD DUCK AT ONCE.
IS HENLEY COLLAR ALL. THE MAPS
IN ITS DO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
BURKE AYE AYE BURKE EYEBROW.
BRAILLE AYE BONTA.
BONTA AYE CHIU.
CHIU AYE GRAY.
GRAY AYE MCCARTY.
CORDY I MELINDA SMOLAN.
MULLIN AYE QUIRK NO QUIRK NO
VOEPEL.
VOEPEL AYE THAT'S OUT FEET.
THAT BILL THAT EIGHT ZERO.
EIGHT ONE EIGHT TO ONE. EIGHT
TWO ONE.
LOW EIGHT TO ONE LIVING TO FILE
ITEM SEVEN AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY
NINE.
MOVE THE BELL.
HOWEVER OTION AND A SECOND WAS
HIGHLY CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS BURKE AYE
BURKE AYE GROW. GROW AYE BONTA.
BONTA AYE CHIU.
CHIU AYE GRAY.
GRAY AYE MCCARTY.
CORDY AYE MELINDA US MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE
VOEPEL.
BUT.
THAT DOES OUT NINE ZERO.
YES
YEAH FILE ITEM EIGHT AB TWENTY
FIVE SEVENTY FOUR. AND IS HIGHLY
CALL THE ABSENTEES.
THE BILL HAS PASSED THE MOTION
WAS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
GRAY.
FILE ITEM A GRAY AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELINDA'S.
MOVING FILE ITEM NINE AB TWENTY
SEVEN HUNDRED.
KALI ABSENTEES.
THAT BILL HAS PASSED THE MOTION
WAS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
GRAY.
GRAY AYE MCCARTY. CURTI AYE
MELINDA'S.
AND I MOVING TO FILE ITEM TEN AB
TWENTY NINE THIRTY SIX.
WE EMOTION A SECOND.
OKAY A MOTION AND A SECOND IS
HIGHLY CALL THE ROLL.
THIS TIME THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS BURKE.
BURKE I WILL. GROW AYE BONTA.
BONTA I CHU. CHU AYE GRAY.
GRAY AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELINDA SMOLAN.
MULLIN I QUIRK NO WORK NO VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I.
THAT'S OUT EIGHT TO ONE LOOMING
A FILE ITEM ELEVEN AB THIRTY
TWENTY NINE.
I AM MOTION AND A SECOND.
WE MOVED. UP ELEVEN FILE ITEM
ELEVEN AB THIRTY TWENTY NINE WE
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
THIS UNCLE THE ROLE THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE AYE AYE
BURKE AYE BROUGH. BRO I BONTA.
BONTA AYE CHU CHU AYE GRAY.
GRAY AYE MCCARTY. CURTI AYE
MELINDA'S MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE QUIRK NOT VOTING
QUIRK NOT VOTING VOEPEL.
VOEPEL AYE IT'S.
THAT GOES EIGHT EIGHT ZERO
MOVING A FILE AND.
LIVING FILE ITEM TWELVE AB
THIRTY SEVENTY NINE.
THIRTY SEVENTY TWO I'M SORRY A.
B. THIRTY SEVENTY TWO.
SEC.
CALDERON.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS BURKE AND I
BURKE AYE BROUGH. ROLE AYE BONTA.
BONTA AYE CHU. CHU AYE GRAY.
GRAY AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELINDA SMOLAN.
MULLIN AYE QUIRK.
I.
QUIRK AYE VOEPEL.
THE PILLOW THAT.
THAT BILLS OUT NINE ZERO MOVING
TO FILE ITEM THIRTEEN CALL THE
ABSENTEES.
BUT AB THIRTY ONE NINETY SEVEN
CALL THE ABSENT
THE BILL HAS PASSED THE MOTION
WAS DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELINDA'S.
NUMBER ONE.
PLAN ON THAT ONE.
OF LIVING BACK TO PILOT A ONE AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY FOUR. CALL THE
ABSENTEES.
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE MELINDA'S.
MERGER AND